oui bienvenue en direct sur Public Sénat
alors nous allons ici faire une pause
dans le débat sur les retraite de 45
minutes pour retrouver l'habituelle
séance des questions cribles institué
depuis la réforme de la Constitution et
la réforme du règlement du Sénat une
séance qui permet à un ministre de
s'expliquer dans un jeu assez rapide
avec les sénateur sur sa politique le
thème des questions cribles aujourd'hui
c'est la politique du logement une
séance qui est présidée par Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat et c'est
donc Benoît Apparu le secrétaire d'État
au logement et à l'urbanisme qui va
répondre aux questions des sénateurs on
rejoint tout de suite l'hémicycle on se
retrouve dans 45 minutes ici juste avant
la reprise du débat sur les retraites
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue
président merci je juste terminer ma
question donc ça tombe
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a une
inquiétude dans les organismes HLM vous
le savez très bien monsieur le ministre
de deux mesures récentes sont
susceptibles de conduire à leur
paupérisation et une papérisation assez
fort de toute la politique du logement
première mesure l'article 99 du projet
de loi de finances projette de soumettre
les organismes HLM à la contribution sur
les revenus locatifs CRL cette
contribution est assise sur les loyers
perçus par les bailleurs institutionnel
or jusqu'ici les organismes HLM a été
exonérés en raison de leur activité
sociale il s'agit d'une ponction des
organismes HLM sur fond de désengagement
de l'État les crédits consacrés à l'aide
à la pierre dans le budget sont en forte
baisse les nouveaux prélèvements viendra
se substituer au financement de l'État
pour le montant de son produit soit 340
millions d'euros par an la deuxième
mesure qui est accentuée qui est une
viille mesure c'est le décret du 21 août
2008 8 qui conduit à une augmentation
importante des surloyers ces deux
mesures combinées auront à mon sens mais
j'espère me tromper peuvent avoir à mon
sens un impact très défast sur le
logement social du fait d' srl les
organismes d'HLM auront bien du mal à
continuer de financer sur leur fond
propre l'entretien du parc et son
extension pour répondre à une demande
sans cesse croissante les organismes
vont s'aauvrir et du fait de l'évolution
incrôler des surloyers c'est la mixité
sociale qui va être mise à mise à mal et
entre les deux c'est un CER vicieux par
parce que sans mixité sociale la
situation financière des organismes ne
risque pas de s'améliorer alors vous me
direz monsieur le ministre que vous
allez me répondre que la péréquation
mise en œuvre profitera l'Île-de-France
mais ce n'est pas au calvados de payer
pour la capitale d'autant que la
capitale a beaucoup d'argent et qu'elle
achète son arg qu'elle achète ses ses
loyers pour être dans les clous de la
loi su qu'elle ch n'arrête pas d'acheter
des immeubles occupés voilà ça c'est un
peu la politique de la ville de Paris
alors voilà là je termine ma question en
disant monsieur ministre avez-vous pris
conscience de ce risque des effets
mécaniquesinduit par par votre politique
sur l'équilibre social et économique des
villes
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Benoît Apparu secrétaire d'État
chargé du logement et de l'urbanisme
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur en fait il y a deux questions
première question la CRL la contribution
sur les revenus locatifs deuxième
question surloyer nous avons
effectivement décidé dans le cadre du
projet loi de financeces de proposer aux
parlementaires la mise en place de cette
CRL pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'on
souhaite organiser une mutualisation
entre les bailleurs sociaux aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez l'équilibre
financier du monde HLM vous apercevez
que la capacité d'autofinancement du
monde HLM est très diverse en fonction
des bailleurs de 5 à plus de 20 %. et
donc nous souhaitons organiser une forme
de péréquation entre le me HLM je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur
quelques éléments un les 340 millions en
question seront inégralement reversé au
monde HLM de ils ne pèseront pas sur les
loyers parce que nous allons en même
temps bloquer ce qu'on appelle l'IRL
l'indice de référence des loyers donc
non cette mesure ne va pas contribuer à
paupériser le monde HLM je rappelle
qu'au-delà des AD la pierre que vous
avez évoqué ce sont 9 milliards d'euros
9 milliards d'euros que
l'État investit dans le monde HLM tous
les ans 4 milliards de de dépenses
fiscal 5 milliards d'euros d'APL au-delà
des a à la pierre et bien évidemment ces
sommesl ne sont absolument pas touchées
dans le cadre de ce budget donc oui
l'État continue à investir massivement
dans le monde HLM et nous souhaitons et
nous souhaitons et nous souhaitons que
l'on continue à battre les records de
production que nous avons depuis l'année
dernière depuis 5 ans maintenant 100000
tous les ans concernant la contribution
sur sur loyer que vous évoquez quelle
est l'idée l'idée c'est justement de se
dire que le monde à Cholem est notamment
là pour loger les plus modestes et quand
vous avez des gens qui ont des r deux
fois le plafond de loyer il est logique
qu'il contribu de façon supplémentaire
au bénéfice du MO h merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur Borgo oui monsieur le
ministre merci de votre réponse c'est
vrai qu'il permettez mes collègues je
peux répondre au ministre merci Monsieur
Donis je
réponds merci de votre réponse parce que
c'est vrai que le monde HLM a beaucoup
d'inquiétude la réponse est claire je
crois qu'il faut que vous ayz un effort
de communication qui soit beaucoup plus
important que ce qu'il a actuellement
mais je vous dis simple heureusement en
fa entre les deux mesures que j'ai fait
exprès d'accoller l'une à l'autre il y a
quand même ce risque d'appauvrissement
il faut faire très attention qu'on
continue pas à créer des ghettos dans
laquelle vous allez avoir des équilibres
sociau économiques dans laquelle vont
s'enfermer les quelques familles qui
seront qui ont beaucoup de problèmes de
sociaux et je crois qu'il est très
important de faire attention à cet effet
mécanique même si je reconnais que
l'effort et la volonté que vous met é
cette mutualisation est
importante
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Jacques mard
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je reviendrai sur l'accession à
la
propriété la politique du gouvernement
en matière de construction depuis 2007
me paraît être un échec puisqu'il y a
une baisse de 25 % du nombre de
logements construits entre 2
et 2009 ça c'est une réalité et cette
politique a été soutenue par des effets
d'annonce suivie de quelques quak comme
la maison à 100000 € la maison à 15 €
par jour et j'en passe malgré cela le 14
septembre 2010 dans votre présentation
de votre réforme vous avez déclaré que
le gouvernement n'avait jamais autant
investi en faveur de l'accession à la
propriété en critiquant les dispositifs
existants en réalité vous avez indiqué
lors d'un récent débat auquel nous avons
participé qu'il allait y avoir une
réduction des crédits en fait on passe
de 7 à 4 milliards d'euros c'est une
curieuse politique pour améliorer le
nombre de construction l'axe de votre
nouvelle politique d'accès au logement
c'est effectivement le renforcement des
du prêt à taux zéro qui passe de 1,2
milliards à 2,6 milliards mais avec en
corrélation la suppression ou la
diminution d'autres fininancement tel
que le crédit d'impôt sur les intérêts
d'emprun immobiliers surtout monsieur le
ministre vous avez eu une illumination
miraculeuse vous avez découvert qu'il y
avait des zones tendues et des zones
détendues et vous en avez conclu qu'au
lieu d'apportter davantage de moyens aux
zones tendues il fallait étrangler les
zones détendues les malheureux de la
zone C moins digne d'intérêt que ceux
des Alpes maritimes ou des hautes scènes
curieuses politiques d'aménagement du
territoire pour les les zones C vous
voulez nous imposer de ne plus
construire du neuf mais de rénover
l'ancien c'est un si si c'est un nouveau
cran vous l'avez d'ailleurs chez une de
vos déclarations c'est un nouveau cran
dans une politique de rupture aggravant
la fracture
territoriale pour la zone C vous nous
dites vous avez peu d'habitants c'est
encore trop si au moins vous augmentiez
le financement des crédits de rénovation
de l'habitat en zone C ce serait moindre
mal et c'est la question que je souhaite
vous poser qu'allez-vous faire pour
faciliter au moins en zone C davantage
de rénovation de l'habitat mais je
crains qu'il n'en soit
rien alors pour vous répondre la parole
est à Monsieur Benoît Apparu vous avez
la parole monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous avez
évoqué là encore deux sujets un
l'accession à la propriété la production
de logement nouveau de les zones tendues
et dites
détendu pour la production de logement
c'est c'est vrai vous avez raison entre
2007 et 2009 il y a eu une baisse de la
production de logement en France on est
passé grosso modo de 437000 435000
pardon année record en 2007 à quelque
chose comme 350 vous pourriez en même
temps préciser qu'il a eu juste un truc
qui s'est appelé la crise et
qu'effectivement la crise a eu des
conséquences également sur la production
de logements sociaux et je tiens à vous
rappeler une chose Monsieur le Sénateur
aucun pays n'a mieux résisté que la
France en matière de production de
logement parce que nous avons fait le
plan de relance qui a permis de soutenir
le secteur de la construction dans notre
pays premier élément de réponse deuxème
élément de réponse oui nous avons décidé
de réaliser l'ambition présidentielle
autour de la France de propriétaire
pourquoi parce que nous considérons que
le taux de propriétaire est trop faible
dans notre pays c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons décidé de remettre à
plat l'ensemble de nos outils pour faire
une chose dépenser moins être plus
efficace et j'avoue être
particulièrement surpris que sur
certains bandes de cet hémicycle
aujourd'hui on se mette à défendre le
crédit d'impôt TPA qui a été vilipandé
depuis 3 ans sur ces bans en question
pourquoi est-ce que nous décidons cette
suppression parce que dans la remise à
plat de l'ensemble de nos outils
d'accession à la propriété nous avons
simplement décidé d'avoir des produits
efficaces des produits pris en compte
par les banques pour la solvabilité des
clients ce n'é était pas le cas des 3
milliards du TPA donc oui nous faisons
d'un côté des économies et de l'autre
nous redistribuons des sommes très
importante au bénéfice de l'accession à
la propriété jamais aucun gouvernement
n'aura fait autant enfin concernant les
zones détendues que vous évoquer à
l'instant qu'est-ce que nous faisons
simplement adapter nos produits et la
réalité des prix si vous aidez de la
même façon dans une zone où vous êtes à
2000 € du mèt carré et dans une zone où
vous avez 7000 € du mèt carré si vous
mettez le même produit à 2000 € du mè
Carr à 7000 € du m² ça veut simplement
dire que personne ne peut être
propriétaire à 7000 € du mè Carr dans
les zones tendues c'est c'est la raison
pour laquelle notre produit s'adapte à
la réalité des prix du marché on pourra
toujours autant construire dans le neuf
dans Z monsieur mard pour merci Monsieur
président monsieur le ministre lorsqu'il
y a un prix de 7000 € le mètre carré ça
veut dire pour 100 m car ça fait 700000
€ faut-il vraiment aider la construction
à ce niveau de prix ça c'est aussi une
vraie question deuxièmement deuxièmement
lorsque vous nous dites jamais on a
autant fait pour l'accession à la
propriété quand on baisse le budget d'un
ministère de 7 milliards à 4 milliards
pour construire je sais pas si c'est un
effort significatif à mon avis c'est une
déclinaison de ce qu'on appelle dans
d'autres secteurs la RGPP et puis je
vais vous donner un exemple pour les 11
départements qui sont en zone C il y a
ici un certain nombre de sénateurs de la
zone C lorsqu'on voudra nos concitoyens
voudront construire dans ces 11
départements et bien à partir du 1er
janvier 2011 Monsieur le Ministre par
exemple pour le prêt à taux zéro au lieu
d'avoir de pouvoir emprunter 63000 € à
taux zéro ils ne pourront plus emprunter
que 31600 €. et bien ça je crois que
c'est tout à fait catastrophique je si
je nous en riscuterons monsieur le
ministre je crois que c'est une réalité
malheureusement merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue philippe Dallier pour le groupe
Union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaitais vous interroger
monsieur le ministre sur la mise en
œuvre du droit au logement opposable
dans la perspective de l'échéance du 1er
janvier 2011 et dans celle du 1er
janvier 2012 effectivement dans quelques
semaines maintenant les délais
d'instruction des dossiers devront être
ramenés de 6 mois à 3 mois de même que
l'État ne disposera plus que de 3 mois
pour trouver une solution pour les
familles qui auront été reconnues comme
prioritaire donc on voit bien que ces
nouvelles conditions vont nécessiter
dans les zones tendues parce que il faut
bien effectivement avoir conscience que
dans les zones entendu le dalallos par
c'est parfois un non sujet mais en
Île-de-France et dans les départements
les plus concernés on sait déjà que les
services instructeurs des dossiers ont
bien du mal à respecter les délais et
que les préfets ont bien du mal derrière
à proposer des logements aux familles
qui ont été désigné comme prioritaire
donc la question est double et je vaux
vous faire part d'une préoccupation de
quel moyen les commissions
disposeront-ell de quels moyens
supplémentaires les commissions
disposeront-elles pour instruire les
dossiers qui vont influer de manière
beaucoup plus nombreuses vous parlez
effectivement de réformer et de
restructurer le questionnaire que les
familles doivent remplir pour
effectivement déposer le dossier ce
questionnaire va être beaucoup plus
conséquent donc un travail
supplémentaire pour les commissions donc
de quels moyens disposeront-elles
pourquoi les commissions n'ont pas
n'ont-elles pas été doublées dans la
région Île-de-France alors que la loi
molle le permettait ce qui effectivement
est une voie d'optimisation en matière
d'accélération des procédures et puis
pendant de la question comment
comptez-vous dans les zones tendues
répondre à la demande sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on n'y parvient pas et
puis le sujet de préoccupation dont je
voulais vous faire part c'est celui de
tous les maires de droite ou de gauche
qui ont des quartiers en difficulté sur
leur communes on sait bien aujourd'hui
que dans ces cas-là souvent tout le
contingent préfectoral c'est Rallo et on
voit bien que l'objectif de mixité
sociale qui est un objectif fondamental
notamment dans les quartiers en
rénovation urbaine mais aussi dans les
autres villes sans quartier en
rénovation urbaine on voit bien que cet
objectif et bien nous le perdons un peu
de vue ce qui est un risque très
important pour l'avenir voilà mes
questions monsieur le ministre monsieur
le ministre pour répondre à Monsieur
Dallier monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur
le le
sénateur la commission de suivi du
dalallo nous a récemment
proposé de reporter l'échéance du 1er
janvier 2011 concernant les délai
d'instruction nous avons décidé de
suivre l'avis de la commission dalallo
et donc nous ne réduiront pas les délais
d'instruction à partir du 1er janvier
2011 premier élément de réponse par
rapport à votre question deuxème élément
de réponse vous poser une question
fondamentale si le relogement d'Allo se
fait dans les quartiers en rue nous
aurons cette difficulté de rajouter
pardonnez-moi l'expression de la
pauvreté à la pauvreté la décision que
nous avons prise lorsque vous nous avons
signé récemment des contrats avec un
certain nombre de bailleurs sociaux
d'Île-de-France c'est effectivement de
mobiliser le contingent préfectoral
parce qu'il est là pour ça pour reloger
des dallo mais à l'exclusion des
quartiers en rue notre accord c'est donc
le suivant nous relogeons les Dallos
dans tous les quartiers sauf dans les
quartiers en rue un certain nombre de
bailleurs sociaux ont accepté de signer
avec nous dans ce sens d'autres ont
refusé signer croyez bien que je le
regrette enfin d'une façon plus générale
concernant le DALO notamment en
île-defance oui c'est c'est vrai nous
avons décidé de mobiliser le comptingent
préfectoral parce que c'est l'outil
principal que nous avons à notre
disposition pour pouvoir répondre à
l'obligation légale que cette majorité a
voté nous sommes nous avons doublé le
nombre de relogements d'Allo ce n'est
pas encore satisfaisant en Île-de-France
même si là encore je me répète sur le
reste du territoire comme vous l'avez
évoqué le DALO aujourd'hui on sait le
gérer la vraie réponse au dalallo c'est
produire produire produire nous devons
produire plus de logement en
l'île-de-fance c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous investissons massivement
au regard des AD laaperre sur
l'Île-de-France pour toujours produire
plus dans cette région particulièrement
tendue et difficile merci Monsieur
Dalier j'utiliserai cette minute
simplement effectivement pour vous
inciter monsieur le ministre à faire en
sorte que dans la région Île-de-France
que je connais le mieux
l'interdépartementalisation devienne une
réalité parce qu'en matière de mixité
sociale régler le problème du dallo à
l'échelle de la sa- sainis entre
communes de sa- sainnis excusez-moi en
matière de mixité sociale ça ne peut pas
fonctionner et le préfet de sainani avec
toute la bonne volonté qui pourra être
la sienne ne réglerait pas les problèmes
qui sont les siens donc la loi molle a
prévu effectivement une vision
interdépartementale des choses j'ai pas
tout à fait le sentiment qu'elle soit
encore rentrée dans les têtes et dans
les faits et notamment en terme de
doublement des commissions la loi le
permet ça n'est pas effectif donc
j'espère simplement que dans les mois
qui part de ses échéances 2000 1er
janvier 2011 et 1er janvier 2012 hein
parce qu'il faut se souvenir que au 1er
janvier 2012 tous ceux qui considèrent
que le délai est anormalement non
pourront déposer un dossier donc on peut
penser qu'à ce moment-là on atteigne les
500 600000 dossiers déposés ce qui est
loin d'être le cas encore aujourd'hui et
si ça devenait une réalité je crois que
nous aurions une grande
difficulté merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue Didier
Guillaume pour le groupe socialiste avez
la parole pour 2 minutes merci Monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues une des premières
priorités de nos concitoyens c'est
l'accès à un logement locatif décent
correspondant à la taille de la famille
et au revenus de la famille la France de
propriétaire c'est bien mais il ne faut
pas opposer l'accession et le logement
locatif social les élus présidents
d'organisme HLM de retour du congrès de
l'ushh dernièrement était déçu et en
colère sur l'annonce de votre budget
monsieur le ministre notamment le budget
du logement ils n'ont pas été élu à tête
de ces organismes HLM pour constituer un
matelas comme cela a pu être suggéré
mais bien pour gérer et pour bien gérer
alors quand vous prévoyez dans le
prochain budget un prélèvement de 2 %
sur les revenus locatifs 340 millions
par an soit un total d'un milliard sur 3
ans un véritable holdup dans leurs
finances vous commettez à mon sens une
double erreur vous soutirez à des
gestionnaires rigoureux une part de
leurs ressources pour combler les
propres carences de l'État en matière de
logement social par cette opération vous
allez priver les locataires des travaux
pour pourtant indispensables que
réalisent avec ses ressources locatives
les bailleurs sociaux construction de
logement neuf travaux de réhabilitation
amélioration de la performance
énergétique vous savez que le problème
de plus en plus crients dans les
collectifs déjà ancien n'est pas le
montant du loyer mais le montant des
charges qui surch iss dangereusement
laquittance mais là vous avez l'air
d'avoir moins d'État d'â pour accepter
les hausses de tarifs d'électricité par
exemple et pour ce poste de dépense pas
d'APL les seules aides étant celles des
départements le fond urgence logement et
le fond énergie alors Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous rassurer les
demandeurs de logement les bailleurs
sociaux les collectivités territoriales
qui sont devenus les premiers
partenaires du logement social et
démontreer ainsi votre engagement en
faveur de l'accès au logement social
allez-vous revenir cette décision qui
met en péril le développement du
logement social en France
Merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Apparu secrétaire d'État chargé du
logement et de l'Urban vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur nous avons effectivement dans
le cadre du budget décidé de mettre en
place une vraie mutualisation entre les
bailleurs sociaux pourquoi parce que
nous considérons
qu'il est en matière de logement comme
dans le cadre de toutes les politiques
publiques nécessaire de procéder à des
économies budgétaire je l'assume
totalement et j'assume cette politique
aujourd'hui le monde HLM c'est une
capacité financière de 6,5 million
d'euros c'est une moyenne en matière de
marge d'autofinancement de 12,5 %
milliard de 12,5 %. c'est donc des
marges considérables sur lesquell nous
avons à travailler ensemble il ne s'agit
pas de dire qu'il y a un matelas dans le
monde HLM il s'agit de dire qu'il y a
des marges de manœuvre et qu'il faut
mutualiser ces marges de manœuvre c'est
la proposition qui est faite et je
répète ce que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
c'estes 340 milliards millions d'euros
pardon seront redistribué à l'UR près au
monde HLM via l'enrue via les aides à la
pierre c'est la décision qui a été prise
par le gouvernement il n'y aura aucun
impact sur le loyer et je vais vous
donner un autre chiffre j'entends
souvent dire que c'est 300 million
d'euros c'est potentiellement 20000
logements de moins que l'on va
construire ou alors des réhabilitations
qui ne seront pas faite je vais vous
citer un autre chiffre si l'engagement
qui a été pris par les bailleurs sociaux
de vendre 1 % du parc HLM était rempli
ce serit 2 milliards d'euros de fonds
propres qui ser réalisé chaque année
c'està-dire 100000 logements sociaux de
plus ça c'est la réalité des
chiffres
merci socialiste une minute monsieur
rentin une minute pour vous dire de
réalités monsieur le Président la
perspective budgétaire de notre pays
pour le logement social c'est 800
millions d'euros en 2008 de dépenses 400
en 2013 c'est inscrit dans la loi de
finances que nous aurons à discuter et
ceci cette diminution partout que nous
soyons en zone tendue comme en zone
détendue puisque cette diminution
s'appliquera partout 2è chose la
ponction d'un milliard d'euros se fera
exclusivement sur les locataires du
monde HLM exclusivement sur les
locataires du monde HLM et sur eux seuls
évidemment il n'y aura pas de
mutualisation puisque cette somme sera
affectée au paiement des dettes de
l'enrue c'est-à-dire des dettes
contractu contractualisé à l'égard de
collectivité locale ou d'organisme HLM
ça n'est donc pas une péréquation c'est
aussi pour payer des aides à la
construction ce n'est donc pas aux
locataires du monde HLM et à eux seuls
de se substituer à la solidarité
nationale monsieur le ministre bien
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue Odette terade pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen les
sénateur du Parti de Gauche vous avez la
parole merci merci monsieur le Président
j'orienterai ma question en lien avec le
débat des retraites sur la problématique
de l'accès au logement des retraités un
récent rapport sur l'état du mallogement
en France de la Fondation abépierre
rappelle que tous les seniiors ne sont
pas riches et bien portant comme Madame
de béancour 600000 personnes âgées
vivent actuellement avec une allocation
de solidarité éta de 628 € ce qui les
place sous le seuil de pauvreté comme 8
millions de nos concitoyens aujourd'hui
dans notre pays comment se loger avec si
peu de ressources votre réforme des
retraites va accentuer ce
dysfonctionnement par un mécanisme très
simple l'allongement des durées de
cotisation cumulé avec le report de 2
années de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite va conduire à une diminution du
montant des pensions pourtant nous
savons très clairement que seul une
politique publique volontaire en matière
de revenus et donc de pension peut
concrètement favoriser l'accès au
logement cela est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui le prix des logements ont
doublé en moins de 10 ans et les loyers
ont augmenté de 30 à 50 % pendant la
même période à l'évidence les ressources
des ménages n'ont pas suivi un tel
rythme ainsi la CLCV et la Fondation
abispierre estime à plus de 500000 le
nombre de ménages qui présentent des
impayés de loyer de 2 mois ou plus soit
une augmentation sur 4 ans de 96 % dans
le parc privé et de 50 8 % dans le
public ceci sans compter les aides
personnelles au logement qui en fonction
de leur faible revalorisation ont
entraîné une diminution de la
solvabilisation de plus de 11 %. cette
perte de pouvoir d'achat s'inscrit dans
le cadre d'une politique de logement
délétaire caractérisé notamment par la
diminution continue des aides à la
pierre notamment par la prochaine
ponction des organismes HLM de l'ordre
de 340 million de par par an et
l'obligation qui leur est faite de
vendre leur patrimoine aujourd'hui il
manque 900000 logements selon la
Fondation abépierre il est clair que
votre gouvernement mène une politique en
rupture avec les valeurs qui sont au
cœur de la République qui sont celles de
fraternité et de solidarité aujourd'hui
c'est à chacun selon ses moyens nous
aurons la retraite obtenue
individuellement par voie de la
capitalisation et non la répartition et
nous pourrons nous loger sous l'unique
condition d'être solevable et
propriétaires oui le logement les
logements sont chers oui les retraites
non uné pourront de moins en moins se
voir garantir un droit au logement et
cela d'autant plus que leur situation
spécifique nécessite bien souvent des
aménagement particulier ma question sera
donc simple quand ce gouvernement
va-t-il entendre et notamment ce jour de
manifestation la voix du peuple plus
particulièrement Monsieur le Ministre
quellees mesures comptez-vous prendre
pour faciliter l'accès au logement de
ces populations fragilisées que même les
bailleurs sociaux hésitent à accueillir
dans leurs
contingents monsieur le
ministre monsieur apparu vous avez la
parole monsieur le le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice la question que vous posez est
une question essentielle dans une pays
dans un pays où la démographie vous en
discutez en ce moment même et vous allez
reprendre ce débat sur les retrait dans
quelques instants où la démographie fait
de notre pays un pays où on vit plus
longtemps et c'est tant mieux nous avons
unbre de questions qui se posent
notamment celle de l'accès au logement
deux réponses à votre question
si nous souhaitons recentrer les
missions du monde HLM sur le logement
des plus modestes c'est justement
notamment pour répondre à la question du
vieillissement de la population que vous
avez évoqué de la même façon si le
gouvernement souhaite accélérer
l'accession à la propriété c'est parce
que l'accession à la propriété c'est
aussi un moyen de préparer la retraite
de sécuriser la retraite de nos
concitoyens c'est ça la réalité c'est ça
la politique que nous menons j'ai
récemment demandé à Madame Boulmier de
me proposer un rapport pour l'adaptation
au vieillissement de la population de
des logements pardon nous avons à la
matière pris un certain nombre de
décisions notamment dans le cadre du
grand emprunt où nous avons
1,25 milliards 1,25 milliards liés à
l'adaptation de nos logements à la
précarité énergétique qui sera lié avec
des travaux permettant d'adapter au
vieillissement de la population ces même
logements je voudrais vous rappeler
deuxème point que l'APL les aides
personneles logement ont augmenté de 6 %
de 6 % ces 3 dernières années justement
pour faire face euh à la problématique
que vous avez que vous avez évoqué à
savoir les difficultés d' de nos
compatriotes et notamment des personnes
âgées à se loger enfin concernant les
340 millions d'euros que vous avez
évoqué à l'instant je voudrais rappeler
une vérité et peut-être la rappeler
également à Thierry Repentin qui
pourtant me semble-t-il connaît bien ces
dossiers-là non ce ne seront pas les
locataires qui paieront cette
contribution pour une raison très simple
nous avons décidé que ce qui était avant
un conseil entre guillemets de l'État
c'est-à-dire l'augmentation des loyer à
l'IRL devient un plafond d'augmentation
qui sera autour de 1 % maximum par an
non les bailleurs sociaux ne pourront
pas répercuter sur les locataires la
contribution en question madame terade
merci et bien ça vous ça ne vous
étonnera pas monsieur le Président je ne
partage pas les les les réponses de de
Monsieur le Ministre certes on vit plus
longtemps mais pour beaucoup on le sait
avec beaucoup moins d'argent et donc
l'illustration dire que les 340 millions
par an des des que les offices HLM vont
devoir payer ne seront pas pris sur le
dos des locataire ça on voudrait bien
voir on sait déjà que forcément c'est
les locataires qui vont payer ça a même
été évalué à 80 € je crois par an 2 %
donc comment ils vont faire ils ils sont
bien obligés et cette mesure en
affaiblissant la capacité de
construction des offices va également se
traduire par une hausse des loyers et
ceci sans compter les fils d'attente des
demandes qui vont s'allonger c'est la
même chose avec le pouvoir de des aPL
quand le revenu maximum des plafonds
était de 2,4 SMIC en 1977 pour une
personne ce n'est plus aujourd'hui que
de 1,07 % du SMIC en 2007 donc on voit
bien qu'il y a la politique du logement
et ces frites donc comment accepter que
cette politique en terme de logement
social soit financée par la seule cont
iution des locataires HLM quand la
nation entière finance le bouclier
fiscal qui correspond aujourd'hui à 640
millions réservés aux 19000 foyers les
plus aisés donc vous comprendrez bien
monsieur le ministre que nous partageons
pas donc vos réponses vous tourner le
dos à une République Solidaire alors
qu'à l'inverse notre groupe nous nous
prononçons pour un grand service public
du logement qui a qui donne le droit au
logement pour tous madame TER merci la
parole est à Monsieur
Jean-François maillet pour le groupe
Union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre cher
collègue le pouvoir d'achat des petits
retraités est aujourd'hui notre
préoccupation c'est le coût de leur
habitation qui pose un vrai problème
dans notre pays devenu en 70 ans un pays
de locataire les 57 % de propriétaires
recensés dans notre pays sont très
majoritairement des Français à l'aise et
les 47 3 % de locataires sont très
majoritairement des français fragilisé
je tire de ce constat la certitude que
c'est à nous les politiques de proposer
des solutions en effet il n'est pas
acceptable de laisser perdurer un
système qui consiste à maintenir au
statut de locataire plusieurs millions
de nos concitoyens à faible revenu en
les subventionnant directement ou
indirectement en passant par les
bailleurs c'est plus de 45 milliards par
an engagés pour supporter ce système qui
éloigne ainsi les bénéficiaires de tout
projet de devenir propriétaire alors
évidemment ils abordent l'âge de la
retraite en situation de locataire
contrain à un loyer qui continue
d'augmenter la charge financière assumé
par la collectivité serait moindre si
nous les avions permis d'accéder à la
propriété au début de leur parcours
résidentiel c'est près de 300 millions
d'euros d'aide à la loocation que peut
cumuler un couple de français avec deux
enfants au cours de son existence je
crois qu'il est temps de remettre cela
en question et de demander aux bailleurs
sociaux de faire accéder à la propriété
massivement et plusutôt j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire que cela valait bien
un complément de retraite les moyens
financiers sont là et des financements
extérieurs sont possibles je
rappelle que 45 milliards d'euros
annuellement dédiés à la loocation
peuvent être progressivement
basculés monsieur le ministre je demande
au gouvernement de revoir le statut des
bailleurs sociaux et d'en faire une
force technique et financière dédiée
prioritairement à l'accession à la
propriété des classes les plus
défavorisé l'État peut leur demander de
vendre l'État peut leur demander de
vendre une partie de leur patrimoine
existant et parfois amorti aux plus
anciens locataires l'État peut leur
demander de
construire pour pri pour faire de
laallocation vente c'est d'ailleurs dans
cet objectif qu'ils ont été créés dans
les années 1920 merci monsieur le
ministre de préciser vos intentions à ce
sujet pour répondre à Monsieur mailler
la parole est à Monsieur Benoît paru
secrétaire d'État chargé du logement et
de l'urbaniste monsieur le le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je connais votre
implication euh dans la question de
l'accession à la propriété et votre
volonté farouche de faire de notre pays
un pays de propriétaire mais qu'on soit
bien d'accord la France de propriétaire
que nous appelons tous de nos vœux je
crois euh c'est augmenter le taux de
propriétaire qui est aujourd'hui vous
l'avez évoqué à 57 %. l'objectif fixé
par le président de la République c'est
d'arriver autour de 70 %. non pas 100 %
parce que si vous êtes à 100 % de
propriétaire ça veut dire qu'il n'y a
plus de mobilité dans le dans le pays et
on a pu voir que les conséquences de la
crise aux États-Unis comme en Espagne
avec des taux de propriétaire plus
élevés étaient malheureusement plus
dramatique que chez nous donc il faut
trouver le bon équilibre entre des
propriétaires et des locataires sans les
opposer je partage totalement votre
analyse sur la nécessité qu'il y a pour
les bailleurs sociaux de vendre une
partie de leur patrimoine nous avons
fixé l'objectif qu'ils vendent 1 % par
an cet objectif progresse le 1 %
logement par exemple tout syndicat
confondu tout syndicat a confondu
accepte maintenant cet objectif de 1 %
le gouvernement dans le cadre des CUS
dans le cadre des conventions d'utilité
sociale va pousser le monde HLM à vendre
une partie de son patrimoine pourquoi
parce que la vente du patrimoine d' HLM
c'est de la mixité sociale en plus c'est
des moyens financiers en plus et c'est
remplir le rêve notamment des des
locataires HLM de devenir eux aussi
propriétaires merci Monsieur Jean
François mailler pour répondre au
ministre je je crois je crois pas
monsieur le ministre qu'on puisse
comparer la France et les États-Unis
mais pour moi je pense qu'il est
vraiment urgent d'arrêter l'aide à la
construction de logement locatif je
crois qu'on est allé trop loin trop fort
et d'une façon trop coûteuse et je crois
qu'il est temps de de dédier les aides
des aides importantes à l'accession à la
propriété des plus faibles je suis je
suis convaincu je suis convaincu que ça
peut marcher il suffit d'essayer merci
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Martial
Bourquin pour le groupe socialiste vous
avez la parole mon le ministre chers
collègues
euh j'ai entendu les différentes
interventions et je voudrais faire trois
remarques la première c'est que la
France des propriétaires ça ne marche
pas en 2007 56 % des Français étaient
propriétaires aujourd'hui malgré la
déductibilité des intérêts d'emprunt les
prê àau zéro la maison à 15 € par jour
et surtout les taux historiquement bas
nous sommes quasiment au même
pourcentage surtout les aides que vous
proposez maintenant je pense notamment
au taux zéro refondu qui est sans
conditions de ressources risque de bénéf
de bénéficier à des personnes qui
avaient déjà un profil d'acheteur idéaux
ensuite je n'ai pas l'impression de voir
les HLM se vider d'un seul coup et des
ménages achetés en masse ce ne sont pas
les mêmes personnes il y a des personnes
solevables qui sont considérées
solevables par les banques des personnes
qui n'ont pas leur prêt concernant les
banques parce qu'ils n'ont pas un emploi
stable et il faudrait faire le point
dans notre pays combien de CDI sont
signés et on sait très bien que ces
prêts sont souvent conditionnés à des
CDI la deuxième chose c'est que la
France des propriétaires faisons
attention ça existait aux États-Unis
ça existait en Espagne et ça a été la
marche forcée une marche forcée dans ces
pays qui s'est révélé un un marche-pied
vers la précarité parfois vers la ruine
de certains propriétaires et ne prenez
pas ces exemple essayons d'avoir une
tradition de notre pays où il y a 10
millions de locataires et il y a aussi
des personnes qui veulent accéder la
proprité il y a les deux et c'est pour
cela que je vous demande monsieur le
ministre que après Didier Guillaume la
suppression de l'exonération de la
contribution des revenus locatifs 340
millions d'euros c'est c'est obéré la
construction de 20000 logements et c'est
100 millions de locataires du parc
social qui vont payer la moitié du
bouclier fiscal ce n'est pas possible on
est dans un pays où il doit avoir un
minimum de solidarité un minimum
d'égalité et ces systèmes anglo-saxons
dont vous vous vous réclamez sont
certainement une impasse et surtout nous
empêche de mettre les les conditions
nécessaires pour avoir un vrai logement
social de qualité dans notre pays pour
vous répondre la parole est Monsieur
Benoît Apparu vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur nous
n'avons peut-être pas effectivement la
même philosophie politique en matière de
politique du logement c'est vrai cette
majorité souhaite que les Français
soient propriétaires il est possible que
de votre côté un certain nombre de
sénateurs socialistes préfère préfère
que les Français soient locataires
j'attire juste votre attention sur un
point j'attire juste votre attention sur
un point il me semble il me semble que
les États généraux du logement qui ont
été organisés par le l'USH l'Union
social pour pour l'habitat nous a appelé
à faire une réforme globale de
l'acessionion la propriété c'est
exactement ce que nous avons fait à la
demande de l'ensemble du monde du
logement dans des états généraux portés
par l'Union Sociale de l'habitat
pourquoi parce qu'il faut arrêter dans
notre pays d'opposer les politiques du
logement oui nous avons dans notre pays
besoin de construire des logements
sociaux mais là encore l'objectif d'une
personne lorsqu'elle rentre dans un
logement HLM c'est pas d'y rester à vie
c'est de progresser dans son parcours
locatif pour un
devenir propriétaire c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous ne souhaitons pas
opposer les politiques les unes aux
autres notre politique c'est de produire
plus de logements sociaux de produire
plus de logements locatifs privés et de
faciliter l'accession à la propriété
c'est ça la politique que poursuit ce
gouvernement monsieur Bourquin vous
monsieur monsieur Berry debas pour une
minute oui merci monsieur le Président
je je voudrais répondre à Monsieur le
Ministre sur le problème quand même des
340 millions qui sont ponctionnés aux
organismes HLM parce que c'est là le le
vrai scandale après avoir je dirais
siphonné le 1 % logement le gouvernement
sous votre autorité monsieur le ministre
s'attaque maintenant à au fonds propres
des organismes HLM 340 millions ça a été
dit par mes collègues c'est 2 %
d'augmentation de loyer qui seront payés
par les plus pauvres pourquoi faèvre
pour remplacer le gouvernement qui est
défaillant sur sa politique en matière
de la h en rue ça il faut le dire
deuxièmement euh qu'est-ce que ça va
traduire pour les collectivités locales
dont nous sommes les représentants ici
ça veut dire que les bailleurs sociaux
vont se tourner vers les collectivités
locales pour remplacer leur politique de
fond propre qui mettait pour le
surenchirissement des coûts de terrain
et pour tenir compte des performances
énergétiques que nous demandons donc ça
se retourne à la fois contre les les
locataires mais ça se retourne également
contre les politiques des collectivités
territoriales auométrique au au premier
titre desquels se trouve les communes la
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
François Noël buffet pour le groupe
Union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
une question
relative à l'application des 20 % de
l'article 55 de la loi SRU
les communes de plus de 1500 habitants
de l'île-de-fance et cell de plus de
3500 habitants sur les autres
territoires ont cette obligation mais la
loi de 2006 a apporté une évolution
puisque pour les personnes ayant accès à
la propriété notamment dans l'accession
sociale à la propriété la loi a permis
que elle soit maintenue dans le Cotat de
logement social mais seulement pour une
durée de 5
années il semble que sur ce point on
pourrait évoluer de de nouveau pourquoi
car monsieur le ministre les personnes
qui sont en possibilité d'accéder à la
propriété en particulier sur l'accession
sociale à la propriété relève
sensiblement du même plafond de revenus
que celle qui ont accès à un certain
type de logement social le fait qu'elle
change j'allais dire qu'elle devienne
propriétaire ne changeant rien leurs
conditions de ressources et les laissent
dans la même situation qu'elles étaient
avant
je crois que il faudrait remettre notre
travail sur le métier pour essayer de
faire évoluer ce texte je sais qu'on
soulève un tabou de parler de la remise
en cause éventuelle de ces 20
% je pense que en réalité ceci pourrait
tout à fait être amendé et pourquoi pas
faire évoluer l'article 55 dans la
mesure où on accepte d'intégrer dans le
logement social l'accession sociale à la
propriété et placer le pourcentage à un
curseur plus haut 25 26 peut-être plus
je ne sais pas cela mériterait d'être
regardé mais en tous les cas que ces
personnes qui accèdent à la propriété
puissent rester dans le quotat des 20 %
je pense que pour les communes c'est
utile ce serait utile pour les communes
qui n'ont pas encore atteint ce
pourcentage mais c'est tout à fait utile
pour les communes qui sont bien au-delà
de ce pourcentage et qui pourrai aussi
avoir intérêt à avoir de l'accession
sociale à la propriété merci pour vous
répondre la parole est à Monsieur Benoît
paru secrétaire d'État chargé du
logement et de l'urbanisme vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre monsieur le
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le le sénateur 1 le
gouvernement reste attaché à
l'application de la loi SRU les 20 % de
logements sociaux dans toutes les
communes depuis 3500 habitants c'est un
élément de mixité j'ajoute un point tout
de suite c'est qu'il me semble de la
même façon qu'aujourd'hui si une commune
a moins de 20 % elle ne respecte pas ces
éléments de mixité de la même façon des
communes qui aujourd'hui ont plus de 50
% de logements sociaux ne respectent pas
plus la mixité et il faut les encourager
à faire plus d'accession à la propriété
vous m'interrogez plus particulièrement
sur le devenir de logements sociaux
vendus à leur locataire qui aujourd'hui
ne reste ne sont pris en compte dans le
quota de 20 % de logements sociaux d'une
commune que pendant 5 ans je suis
attaché à cette mesure pourquoi parce
que l'objectif même d'un logement social
n'est pas qu'une personne y reste à vie
nous souhaitons encourager la rotation
dans le parc HLM sauf à partir du moment
où vous sortez un logement social du
parc locatif pour le mettre dans le parc
de propriétaire il ne participe plus à
cette rotation du parc HLM c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis attaché à
cette règle de 5 ans qui me paraît un
bon équilibre entre la nécessité
d'encourager les bailleurs sociaux à
vendre une partie de leur parc HLM et la
nécessité d'assurer la rotation enfin
j'ajoute un dernier point 5 ans c'est la
bonne durée me semble-t-il pour
construire de nouveaux programmes de
logement soci notre objectif il est très
clair encourager les bailleurs sociaux à
vendre du parc HLM pour construire de
nouveaux logements
sociaux merci monsieur le sénateur pour
répondre au ministre oui je n'ai pas la
prétention de répondre au ministre mais
je souhaite qu'effectivement on
s'inscrive dans une logique de parcours
résidentiel et que le fait de que des
locataire accède à la propriété à
l'accession sociale à la propriété
permet aussi de libérer du log social
pour ceux qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent
accéder au logement social compte tenu
de la situation un peu de blocage et
c'est en ça que j'y vois un intérêt
indépendamment du fait que les bailleurs
sociaux retrouvent aussi une capacité
budgétaire pour pouvoir réinvestir et
que le système finalement ne peut se
voir à travers le prisme simplement
d'une typologie de logement mais à
travers un ensemble il me semble que
c'est sur ce pointl qu'il faudrait
travailler
merci chers collègu merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci mes chers cègues
maintenant suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 18h et se poursuivra le soir
avec à l'ordre du jour la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi portant
réforme des retraites la séance est
suspendue voilà vous venez de suivre la
séance des questions cribles au Sénat
sur la politique du logement une forme
de parenthèse avant que euh j'allais
dire les choses sérieuses non là vous
l'avez entendu c'est est effectivement
sérieux mais en tout cas le dossier le
plus complexe du moment ne reprenn droit
de citer ici au Sénat avec la suite du
débat sur les retraites un débat qui
pourrait se prolonger jusqu'à la fin de
la semaine prochaine alors que les
sénateurs vont commencer à examiner à
partir d'ici un quart d'heure l'article
1 du projet de loi sur la réforme
puisque les articles décisifs les plus
symboliques ont été adopté en fin de
semaine dernière et hier sur le report
de l'âge légal de la retraite à 62 2 ans
à 67 ans pour la borne d'âge sans
décotes s'il en a pas cotisé assez
longtemps ça c'était hier soir et donc
on va reprendre le texte maintenant à
l'endroit par les articles du début
alors 880 et quelques amendements encore
à discuter et un débat qui s'annonce
très long et l'article 1 donc qui va
être débattu tout à l'heure à mes côté
le secrétaire d'État en charge de la
fonction publique qui pilote ce débat
parlementaire au côté du ministre Eric
ver George Tron bonjour bonjour ce soir
la CFDT annonce 3 millions et demi de
manifestant au-delà de la bataille des
chiffres la mobilisation ne faiblit pas
comment vous réagissez à cela en
mesurant que si elle ne faiblit pas
c'est parce que l'exercice d'explication
n'est pas suffisant il y a eu des
avancées très importantes au Sénat
notamment concernant les femmes mères de
trois enfants comme il y en avait eu à
l'Assemblée nationale on est donc dans
une logique qui va continuer à à
justifier les explications que l'on doit
donner il est évident que personne ne
remet en cause de personne de sérieux ne
remet en cause la nécessité de la
réforme cette réforme est une réforme
plus douce que celle qu'on a mis en
œuvre dans tous les pays qu'on nous
entour dans le consensus en France le
consensus n'existe pas et bien il faut
qu'on soit plus pédagogue et qu'on en
prenne note simplement oui mais vous
l'avez déjà été pédagogue les arguments
on les entend j'allais dire presque en
boucle depuis quelques semaines et
malgré ça il y a toujours autant de
monde dans la rue maintenant il y a les
jeunes qui s'y mettent aussi comment
est-ce qu'on va sortir de ce face à
faceace apparemment sans issu pour
l'instant en continuant à expliquer les
choses c'est pas très difficile
d'expliquer à des jeunes je suis père de
famille j'ai 3 ans enfants qui ont 18 19
et 20 ans je leur explique sans beaucoup
de difficulté que si aujourd'hui pour
payer 35 milliards d'euros de de pension
j'emprunte 35 milliards d'euros sur les
marchés à 20 ou 25 ans c'est eux qui
vont rembourser voilà c'est aussi simple
que cela c'est eux qui vont rembourser
c'est la première fois honnêtement que
l'on est confronté à une explication qui
me paraît autant tomber sous le bon sens
on emprunte aujourd'hui pour payer les
retraites d'aujourd'hui comme on
emprunte aujourd'hui pour payer les
l'assurance maladie d'aujourd'hui on
essaie de mettre en place un dispositif
pour éviter de laisser le fardeau de nos
dettes à nos enfants et bien je vous le
dis non pas en tant que ministre je vous
le dis en tant que père de famille moi
voilà je pourrais descendre dans la rue
pour expliquer à des jeunes ce qu'il en
est et leur dire voilà vous êtes en
train de faire en sorte de convaincre
que c'est finalement mieux de vous
laisser des dettes plutôt que de les
prendre à notre charge je vous laisse
deviner combien je mise sur le bon sens
pour penser que l'explication que je
viens de vous donner en quelques mots
peut passer et c'est vraiment donc se
face à face avec les jeunes vous êtes
prêts à le faire mais c'est pas un face
à face avec les jeunes je sais que dans
toutes les questions qui n sont poser
c'est ce que c'est ce que voilà on
aspire à ça il faut que ce soit un
combat un bras de fer quelle cartouche
on va dégainer je ne suis pas dans la
bataille je n'en veux à personne je ne
suis en guerre contre personne et encore
moins contre les jeunes contre les
autres c'est pas une question de de
combat c'est pas une question de gagner
c'est une question simplement de savoir
si oui ou non il y a du bon sens à faire
ce que nous faisons et la réponse est
oui il y a du bon sens à faire ce que
nous faisons comme il y a du bon sens à
expliquer au sénateurs socialiste en ce
moment que si on prétend trouver 35
milliards d'euros par l'impôt ben ça va
veut dire qu'on va augmenter massivement
les impôts pour tous les Français et
puis ça veut dire en second lieu que si
la crise intervient à nouveau et que les
recettes fiscales s'ffondent on pourra
plus payer les retraites voilà alors
néanmoins il y a non non non non c'est
pas ça il y a un risque aujourd'hui de
blocage ça veut dire que malgré tout il
y a une forme de malaise ou une forme
d'inquiétude qui s'exprime dans
l'opinion chez les salariés chez ceux
qui bloquent les ports les raffineries
aujourd'hui mais non monsieur c'est pas
la logique des choses il suffit pas de
bloquer suffit pas de de manifester pour
avoir raison c'est pas dans un conseil
municipal celui qui écrit le plus fort
qui a raison c'est pas celui qui il y a
une logique d'explication j'ai au côté
d'éc vert entendu à l'Assemblée au Sénat
dans chaque groupe des voix qui sont des
voix de mesures et des voix de
proposition et puis j'entends également
des voix qui sont des voix plus
excessives il y a 2 millions et demi
peut-être 3 millions de personnes qui
manifestent c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup et je je j'interprète
exactement leur message pour la majorité
d'entre eux en tout cas comme étant un
message d'inquiétude et puis il y a 62
millions de gens qui ne manifestent pas
et donc je puis vous dire parce que les
messages il nous les envoi mais c'est
pas manifest manifestant qu' le font
pour nous dire on est bien conscient de
ce qu'il faut faire on n'est pas dans un
rapport de force et un gouvernement
responsable ne veut pas de rapport de
force donc je ne rentre pas dans une
logique de rapport de force je dis
simplement cette réforme est une réforme
qui n'a rien d'original on n'est pas le
seul pays au monde à le faire on est le
dernier c'est tout à fait différent donc
on est dans une logique est une logique
de dialogue j'ai passé avec Eric vert à
peu près les 4 5e de mon temps sur 24
heures depuis une semaine ici j'avais
fait la même chose à l'Assemblée
nationale je dialogue j'explique et puis
je continue à le faire parce que c'est
c'est la logique bien sûr que je vais
continuer il faudra le faire et et si
dans un pays au bout d'un moment on dit
on est plus dans une logique de
discussion et dans une logique de
rapport de force si c'est par le nombre
de manifestants que l'on voit ce que
l'on pèse on est plus dans un régime
parlementaire et démocratique il y a des
élections en 2012 que ceux qui ont
quelque chose à dire à ce moment-là le
le dis avec force je me permets de
signaler d'ailleurs c'est une question
sur laquelle j'attire votre attention
que j'entends des voix maintenant parti
socialiste commencer à prendre
conscience de ce que nous disons depuis
des semaines et des semaines quand
j'entends monsieur stroskan ce que
personne ne relève j'ai pas une question
là-dessus quand j'entends monsieur
stroskan nous dire que la France fait ce
qu'il faut faire et que la réforme est
une réforme de bon sens quand j'entends
Monsieur Hollande ce matin expliquer que
il commence à s'interroger sur
l'attitude du Parti socialiste quand je
lis monsieur Rocard avanthier dans un
grand journal du soir dire que il
désavoue ses camarades du Parti
socialiste je m'aperçois qu'en réalité
il y a pas les bons d'un côté les
méchants de l'autre non il y a ceux qui
essaient d'avancer qui font attention
aux évolutions de la société puis il y a
ceules qui sont toujours dans la
confrontation moi le gouvernement nous
ne sommes pas dans la confrontation
merci beaucoup George Tron je vous
laisse donc rejoindre l'hémicycle ou va
se poursuivre ce débat dans un instant
avec nous l'ancien Premier ministre
Pierre Moroi vous l'avez entendu en tout
cas le gouvernement c'est ce que dit
George Tron c'est son message n'a pas du
tout l'intention de céder un pouce de
terrain malgré la mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui avant de de retrouver
pierre Morois qui me rejoint à mes côtés
tout de suite un détour par la place de
de la Bastille où se trouve notre envoyé
spécial Marie bremon mot au cœur de de
cette manifestation avec Marie une
mobilisation qui visiblement ne faiblit
pas aujourd'hui hein même s'il va y
avoir encore ce soir bataille de
chiffres B oui comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi la place de la Bastille
continue de se remplir il faut dire que
les deux cortèges parisiens étent noir
de monde d'ailleurs selon les premiers
chiffres qu'il soit de sources
policières ou syndicales il y avait plus
de monde aujourd'hui dans les rue de
Paris et dans toute la France que lors
des journées d'action précédentes ce qui
est peut-être nouveau aujourd'hui he
c'est la présence en masse de lycéens et
d'étudiants qui dans les cortèges
côtoyer les salariés et les retraités il
y a une espèce de front unitaire qui se
construit contre la réforme des
retraites mais la radicalisation du
mouvement s'exprime par un ralebol
général du coup les revendications
portent sur les retraites mais pas
seulement elles pent également sur les
salaires l'avenir ou encore contre un
système politique en général merci Marie
donc place de la Bastille au cœur de la
manifestation station à Paris on vous
retrouvera tout à l'heure avec Michel
grossior dans le journal de 19h pour
faire le point à mes côté le sénateur
socialiste ancien Premier ministre
Pierre Morois monsieur Moroi bonsoir On
vient de l'entendre la mobilisation n'a
pas n'a pas faibli en même temps le
gouvernement lui reste tout à fait
oui de plus en plus nombreux et en plus
de ça la plateforme des revendication
c'est largie quoi on est sur les
retraites mais on est aussi sur les
salaires B il y a un ralbol général quoi
alors comment est-ce que on on peut
sortir de cette situation alors même que
le gouvernement on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure par la voie de George Tron n'a
pas n'a plus l'intention de bouger d'un
pouce sur ce projet de vois sur les
retraites voilà problème est là il ne
veut pas
bouger ce qui nous concerne on continue
la bataille voyez bien la bouteille
d'amendement qui n'en finit pas on
finira pas en fin de semaine il faudra
attendre le début de la semaine
prochaine pour ma part j'ai essayé de de
faire une intervention d'émotions quoi
pour vraiment protester contre la
disparition de cette retraite à 60 ans
rien n fait il reste
inébranlable en même temps la retraite à
60 ans c'est
1981 voilà mais là ça n'était qu'un
aspect j'aurais l'occasion la semaine
prochaine ou même ici en fin de semaine
de développer ce que nous pensons en ce
qui concerne l'avenir quoi voilà parce
que cétait une époque le monde a changé
les contraintes mais c'est eux qui ne
veulent pas changer écoutez il y a
quelque chose de clair qui n'est
absolument pas abordé par eux et qui est
vraiment le problème essentiel c'est
qu'il y a de plus en plus de
retraités il y a de plus en plus hélas
de chômage dans ces conditions là ce ne
sont pas ceux qui sont en activités qui
peuvent satisfaire finalement à tous les
crédits qu'il faut pour sur les
retraites ça c'est la fin du système par
répartition alors mais non pas du tout
au contraire mais il faut à tout prix
pas y ajouter tout de même ça me paraît
tout à fait
indispensable garder le système de
répartition bien entendu mais y ajouter
des contributions qui soi des
contributions venant du capitali c'est
indispensable faute de
quoi on aura pas les crédits suffisants
ils veulent pas comprendre ça là on voit
bien qu'on est trop àétriqué quoi qu'il
est indispensable d'avoir quelques
moyens supérieurs la gauche fait des
propositions j'aurais l'occasion d'y
revenir sur tout ce qui serait possible
sur ce plan là mais vous voyez que tous
les socialistes ne sont pas d'accord
puisque Michel Rocard semble lui ouvert
un reculage de la retraite on a même
entendu le FMI doncard écoutz c'est un
ami de jeunesse que j'aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs et c'est un ami enfin bref il
est dans l'Arctique l'Antarctique et
cetera il est un peu C
très bien alors il fait quelques
ouvertures mais il a T de faire quelques
ouvertures nous nous restons ferm
voilàis d'un
gouvernement avec un président de la
République qui rencontre énormément de
difficulté devant
l'opinion avec un ministre qui défend
les
retraité qui défend aussi une retraité
particulière pas et
qui vraiment soulève
un certain dégoût quoi de la part des
Français des Françaises pensez que ça
reste dans les esprits cette affaire d
ça revient sans cesse c'est pas oublié
même s'il continue lui à non mais ce
n'est pas ça n'est pas oublié du tout
d'utant plus que c'est tout à fait
scandaleux quoi donc à ce moment ici au
moment on discute des retraites et
certaines retraites cyezle elles sont
véritablement insuffisante mais on pose
même pas ce problème non on pose le
problème de pas que de l'assurer ses
retraites et pour l'assurer il y a un
nom de mesures à prendre le gouvernement
a fait des propositions et il reste
bloquer sur ces propositions elles
suffisent
pas moi j'ai participé je vois hier là
tous les amendements par moment il y
avait la possibilité tout de même
d'ajouter un petit geste de générosité
et cetera non le gouvernement s refuse
il reste bloqué sur ses positions non je
pas euh quel que soit d'ailleurs je sais
pas ce que ça va donner pas dans ces
conditions quel que soit le résultat
c'est dans la mémoire des Français et ça
ils s'en rappelleront au moment au
moment des élections au moment des
élections des élections merci merci
beaucoup pierre MAOI ancien Premier
ministre on n'oublie pas
qu'effectivement c'est lorsque vous
étiez Premier ministre qui a été voté
vous en parliez un instant la retraite à
60 ans qui a remise en cause aujourd'hui
on va accueillir votre collègue oui elle
a été votée et nous nous avons été
pendant 23 ans dans l'opposition voilà
alors on voit pas tous ces milliers ces
milliers de Français le temps qu'il a
fallu attendre pour avoir la retraite à
60 ans ça mérite quand même une certaine
considération même s'il faut la dépasser
si nous avons des propositions à faire
pour garantir merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup pierre Morrois
nous accueillons Catherine main de s
sénatrice centriste merci d'être avec
nous alors bonour on sait que ici les
les centristes ont un poids politique
important puisque l'UMP n'a pas la
majorité à elle toute seule je voudrais
savoir d'abord comment vous réagissez
quand vous voyez que dans la rue la
mobilisation n'a pas faibli
35 selon la la CFDT les chiffres bien
sûr du ministère de l'Intérieur seront
inférieurs mais néanmoins il semble que
le Paris des syndicats de continuer à
mobiliser soit un Paris ce soir réussi
il est vrai que c'est le moment pour les
uns et les autres de se mobiliser s'ils
ne sont pas d'accord avec un ensemble de
dispositions qui sont prévues
dans la loi euh au demeurant l'examen de
ce texte n'est pas terminé nous
continuons les débats sereinement
tranquillement ça prend forcément du
temps c'est un texte important et c'est
normal qu'il pose des questions aux uns
et et aux autres s'agissant des
centristes nous nous sommes mobilisés
comme vous l'avez vu sur une loi plus
juste plus solidaire plus équitable
notamment au sur la question des femmes
sur laquelle je suis personnellement
intervenue hier il y aura des questions
dans les jours à venir aussi sur la
pénibilité comment on peut constituer
peut-être à la manière de ce qui se fait
pour euh les personnes souffrant des
effets de la miande comment on peut
constituer en amont avant que les gens
ne soient affectés directement euh par
soit des maladies soit l'impact de la
vie professionnelle comme on peut aussi
constituer des fonds qui permettent en
reconnaissant certains métiers de partir
plus tôt euh à la la retraite c'est la
borne d'âge 65 67 ans je crois qui
inquiète le plus et vous pensez qu'on
peut encore jouer là-dessus même si le
gouvernement a dit qu'il n'irait pas
plus loin que les dernières concessions
qu'il a fait sur cette borne d'âge
écoutez tant qu'on débat moi je
considère que le principe de la
séparation des pouvoirs doit être réel
il y a l'exécutif d'un côté qui a son
point de vue il y a le législateur qui a
aussi son point de vue de l'autre les
entrés sont législateurs investis et
responsables ils entendent que le projet
de loi soit un peu plus équilibré en
faveur justement des questions de la
pébilité des questions des ils entendent
aussi à ce qu'on puisse prendre en
compte la la perspective d'une réforme
plus structurelle à terme hein nous
avons un certain nombre d'amendements et
qui font nous demandons un rapport au
gouvernement vers pour aller vers une
réforme dite à point une réforme donc
beaucoup plus structurelle qui tienne en
compte les évolutions de de de la
société notamment tout ça ça reste
encore en débat et et en discussion donc
nous avançons hein nous avançons dans le
texte ça prend forcément un peu de temps
ant les Français enfin les manifestants
sont mobilisés il y a des grèves dans
les raffineries dans les ports
pétroliers on a le sentiment que il y a
une forme de crise sociale l'arvé qui
est en train de de monter comment est-ce
que on en sort il y a surtout une
attente de voir comment le projet de loi
va évoluer va peut-être plus plus de
d'équité notamment toujours dans cette
je crois que les les Français sont quand
même responsables ils ont bien
conscience que à l'instar de ce qui
s'est fait dans les pays de l'OCDE il
faut constatant l'accroissement de la
vie de 6 années dans les 10 dernières
années il faut bien prendre en compte ce
paramètre et effectuer ce pachass de 60
à 62 ans moi je je le soutiens c'est
responsable de le de le soutenir
aujourd'hui au demeurant il y a des
amélioration encore sur cette fameuse
borne 65 67 ans c'est un éable et les
questions de pénibilité merci beaucoup
Catherine Morin de sali sénatrice donc
du groupe
centriste donc pour cette cette réaction
réaction également ce soir du sénateur
UMP des ivelines alain GOURNAC qui est
avec nous alain GOURNAC on avait notre
envoyé spécial place de la Bastille un
instant beaucoup de manifestants la
mobilisation continue des jeunes aussi
qui se sont joints à ce mouvement est-ce
que la majorité le gouvernement peuvent
se contenter d'une fin de de non
recevoir face à cette mobilisation qui
ne faiblit pas et donc qui a sans doute
une signification même si vous n'en
partagez pas les motivations de fond
alors d'abord moi je veux dire non il
faut respecter moi j'ai beaucoup de
respect tout le monde sait ici pour les
syndicats ils ont un rôle extrêmement
important dans le monde du travail et
dans le monde en général donc non on
peut pas on ne peut pas dire qu'on
entend pas ce qu'ils disent mais je
pense aussi une autre chose c'est que de
temps en temps il faut être unpulaire il
faut accepter d'être unpulaire pour
faire passer une réforme qui est une
réforme nécessaire oui ou non voulezous
défendre une une un système de retraite
peut-être que non certains vont dire
mais non il faut des retraites privées
il faut des point moi je crois très
sincèrement que notre retraite je dis
pas qui est parfaite hein j'ai jamais
dit ça mais va quand même dans le bon
sens et nous permet de regarder en 2014
puisquon va faire le point et là aussi
on écoutera les choses en 2014 et de
voir si en 2018 cela ça règle ça amène à
régler la les difficultés rencontrées
pour payer on a l'impression quand même
d'un dialogue de Sour qui est en train
de s'engager le gouvernement a fait des
concessions dont il a laissé entendre
que c'était les dernières la Russe fait
entendre de plus en plus forte vous
craignez pas un risque de blocage du
pays alors n'importe comment je vous dis
hein il faut savoir moi je suis très
inquiet je vais vous dire plus inquiet
et vous l'avez dit dans votre question
c'est la participation des jeunes parce
que les jeunes quand ils viennent dans
les manifestations j'ai j'étais bien
placé au moment du CPE pour savoir qu'il
faut y faire extrêmement attention mais
qu'il y ait un mouvement important je
suis plus inquiet par par l'histoire de
l'essence je suis beaucoup plus inquiet
par les dockers je vous le dis tout de
suite c'est pas pour minimiser ce qui se
passe à à à Paris et dans toutes les
villes de France je crois qu'il faut
regarder ça et surtout si je suis en
désaccord total avec l'argumentation du
parti socialistes je suis pas en
désaccord avec
certaines propositions et certaines
avancées des syndicats en France alors
vous vous parliez de de votre inquiétude
sur les dockers est-ce qu'on risque de
revivre des situations de blocage comme
en 95 voir la dernière grande pénurie
d'essence en France éit mais 68 et bah
ça serait beaucoup très bon pour le
président de la République hein parceque
vous savez que la dernière fois quand il
a pas eu d'essence dès qu'on a mis trois
goouttes d'essence dans les voitures
automatiquement général de Gaulle s'est
trouvé extrêmement populaire donc il
joue le pourrissement de la situation
Nicolas Sarkozy je ne dis pas ça mais je
dis que les syndicats doivent faire
attention il peut y avoir regardez au
début c'était populaire enfin c'était
populaire tout le monde disait autour de
nous oui il faut réformer le système de
retraite et puis les choses se sont
retournées ça peut aussi se retourner
dire que la popularité du mouvement
actuel ne dirait pas forcément s'il y
avait vraiment une gêne quti pour
l'ensemble des Français moi je le pense
les Français sont weekend désolé je veux
pas les critiquer j'en suis un mais les
Français sont weekend ils veulent leur
voiture c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important toucher alors au
réservoir d'essence ou de fuel ça serait
quelque chose qui serait certainement
pas quelque chose qui permettra aux
Français de se mettre de ce côté quelle
réponse Nicolas Sarkozi doit-il apporter
personnellement est-ce qu'il doit
intervenir une nouvelle fois sur ce
dossier il doit être plus attentif ils
doivent montrer moi lui conseille moi
j'ai voté pour lui je le soutiens alors
donc on peut pas CR c'est pas
franchement une surprise vous êtes au
groupe UMP aisolument encore que
peut-être le vote est secret bon mais
moi ce que je dis simplement que le
Président de la République se montre
attentif à ces mouvements il est passé
je pense pas assez il part au Vatican il
fait toutes sortes de choses qui est
très bien mais je pense qu'il doit aussi
avoir un regard sur ces Français qui
sont dans la rue inquiet et d'ailleurs
dans la rue ils viennent apporter une
inquiétude qui dépasse les retraites moi
c'est mon avis donc il faut la
considérer on peut pas dire bah vous
avez tant de millions de de Français qui
sont dehors bah oui bah ils se promènent
non certainement pas je crois que le
prés et tout le monde tout le personnel
politique doit faire très très attention
à respecter les syndicats je le dis en
particulier j'ai aucune aucun soutien
vis-à-vis du Parti socialiste qui est
pour moi IR responsable mais pas les
syndicats je ne mets pas du tout voyez
je fais la part des choses entre les
deux merci beaucoup alain GOURNAC
sénateur UMP desivelines alors le débat
vous l'avez entendu et vif ici au Sénat
euh la situation semble bloquée dans le
rapport de force entre la rue d'un côté
le gouvernement de l'autre comment va se
dérouler maintenant la discussion dans
l'hémicycle et ben on va le suivre tout
de suite en retrouvant donc les les
débats puisque la discussion reprend à
l'article 1 alors ce sont des articles
qui sont pas forcément les les plus
importants assez formels sur le pilotage
du système de retraite le rôle du
Conseil
mais AC beaucoup d'amend qui vont sans
doute permettre à l'opposition de monter
au crneau en faisant le lien entre la
mobilisation de la rue et ce qui se
passe ici dans l'hémicycle tout de suite
donc la séance c'est en direct sur
public les acquis sociaux avec les
articles 5 et 6 bref solder ce comité
Théodule extérieur au véritable
détenteur de de la légitimité à savoir
les
élus je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est àieur Monsieur
telade Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE ch monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers
collègues dans ce débat qui n'est pas
nouveau qui est un peu passionné ce qui
est tout à fait
normal nous vous proposons un amendement
de repli oh je ne dis pas qu'il peut
faire l'unanimité mais qui à propos de
notre fameux comité peut-être pourrait
pour pourrait-on trouver une solution
qui donne satisfaction à beaucoup en
effet à l'alinéa
4 nous avons le comité de pilotage a
pour mission de veiller nous nous vous
proposons de remplacer cette expression
le comité de pilotage fait des
propositions au gouvernement et au
Parlement afin que ceci veille et cetera
en effet ce n'est pas au comité de
pilotage d'assurer un contrôle sur les
régimes de retraite c'est pas nouveau
d'ailleurs tous les débats qui ont eu
lieu et tous les rapports qui ont été
faits dans le domaine des retraites ont
toujours essayé de donner à ces comités
de pilotage un rôle qui est le leur qui
n'est pas le rôle des élus il ne doit
pas se substituer en aucun cas au
pouvoir législatif et à travers cet
amendement nous poursuivons le principe
précédemment énoncé et je le répète le
comité de pilotage ne doit pas
se substituer au gouvernement et au
Parlement ni au Comité d'Orientation des
Retraites ce serait une erreur ce la
création de ce Comité tel qu'il est
présenté consiste aujourd'hui à diminuer
le rôle du Parlement et vous neons vous
ne pouvez pas nous faire accepter qu'un
comité composé de gens qui n'ont pas la
légitimité issue du suffrage universel
décide à la place de ceux qui l'ont à la
lecture des différents alinéas nous
décelons d'ailleurs les intentions
cachées dans la création de ce Comité
certains mots cachent les réalités ainsi
il est indiqué à l'alinéa 4 qu'une de
ces missions sera de veiller à ce que
nos retraites par répartition restent au
cœur du pacte social qui unit les
générations c'est un grand principe et
nous sommes attachés à son respect mais
ce principe est-il au rendez-vous alors
que le passage de 60 à 62 ans touchera
ceux qui auraient pu bénéficier d'une
retraite à taulein à 60 ans est-il au
rendez-vous alors que le passage de 65 à
67 touchera les personnes
essentiellement nos collègues femmes qui
n'arrivent à avoir une retraite à tau
plein qu'en atteignant l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et qu'en est-il
pour nos jeunes aujourd'hui qui quand
ils ont la chance de rentrer sur le
marché du travail rentre tard quel va
être leur avenir travailler jusqu'à 70
ans l'est-il encore alors que le
financement des 45 milliards de déficit
se fera nécessairement pour parti par
une diminution des prestation servie et
que contre toute vérité on annonce le
contraire d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
l'opinion publique ne le croit plus
peut-on parler d'équité lorsque les
efforts fiscaux nécessaires ne
concerneront pas les bénéficiaires du
bouclier fiscal et qu'il touche à 90 %
les salariés alors telles sont les
réflexions qui nous ont inspirer et que
nous inspire ce comité ah j'hésite à
dire comité Théodule car c'est un peu
méprisant mais dans l'utilité de faire
semblant et de masquer les incohérences
de votre texte et disons-le aussi en
définitive dans le domaine des retraites
de masquer aussi votre
politique
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur café vous avez la
parole chers
collègu merci le monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues nous sommes comme
Annie David c'està-dire que les
explications du rapporteur et du
ministre que nous avons attendu avant
l'interruption ne nous ont absolument
pas
convaincu et la conviction que c'est une
habitude et la conviction que nous avons
c'est que cet article a été rédigé selon
le précepte de George Clémenceau
précepte selon lequel pour enterrer un
problème il suffit de créer une
commission et monsieur le ministre il
est vrai depuis le début de ce débat que
des problèmes que vous voulez enterrer
il y en a une multitude sauf un je vous
le concède c'est celui de l'équilibre
financier des régimes mais sachez
monsieur le ministre que cette
préoccupation des de l'équilibre
financier nous l'avons sinon autant que
vous au moins plus que vous et
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
et ça a été fort bien résumé par notre
président de groupe Jean-Pierre belle
tout à l'heure nous avons présenté une
réforme
alternative avec un plan de financement
qui lui assure la pérennité de ses
réimes de retraite à l'horizon en tout
cas 2020 et Monsieur le Ministre euh
je me je rajouterai puisque je vois que
j'ai encore un peu de temps les
principales caractéristiques de ce que
nous avons proposé c'est-à-dire une
réforme beaucoup plus juste beaucoup
plus équilibrée beaucoup plus équitable
que la vôtre que la vôtre parce que vous
avez choisi de faire peser la
quasittalité de l'effort sur les
salariés mais là n'est pas l'essentiel
monsieur le ministre l'essentiel c'est
la rédaction de cet article vous nous
avez expliqué longuement que ce comité
de pilotage serait chargé bien
évidemment de réfléchir de faire des
propositions sur des choses aussi
importantes que la la solidarité pardon
Inter et
intragénérationnelle sur le maintien
d'un niveau de vie satisfaisant pour les
salariés monsieur le ministre si tel
était le cas vous n'auriez pas rédigé
cet article tel qu'il est à l'heure
actuelle regardons-le trois alinéas le
premier fait référence aux objectifs du
code de la sécurité sociale les deux qui
viennent ensuite sur 3 deux alinéas sur
3 ne posent qu'une question celle de
l'équilibre financier c'est la seule
fonction à mon sens que vous assignez à
ce comité de pilotage et je note au
passage monsieur le ministre que si vous
imitez tant d'insistance c'est que
probablement vous doutez de l'efficacité
de ces mesures pour assurer la pérenité
de l'équilibre financier alors que le
nôtre a priori jusqu'à présent je n'ai
pas entendu de votre part de démenti sur
cette question essentielle si tel était
le cas encore monsieur le ministre le
rapport de notre Commission ne serait
pas rédigé ainsi car dès le début dès le
départ la mèche est vendue regardons la
page 58 la page 58 nous dit tout
simplement que cet article a pour objet
de créer le comité de pilotage des
régimes de retraite nouvelle instance
chargée du pilotage stratégique du
système de retraite afin de veiller
notamment et tout est probablement dans
le notamment mais en tout cas afin de
veiller notamment au retour à
l'équilibre financier à l'horizon 2018
dès la première phrase sur cet article
dans le rapport la mèche est vendue et
vous faites l'aveu que la seule chose
qui vous préoccupe ça n'est pas l'équité
ça n'est pas l'efficacité c'est
l'équilibre financier au détriment de
tout le reste et quand je disais
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure que
il y avait une multitude de problèmes
que vous vouliez passer sous la table je
pense notamment par exemple à l'équité
entre les hommes et les femmes à leurs
inégalités dans la retraite je pense par
exemple à la pénibilité du travail dont
vous affirmez qu'elle a été réglée par
les mesures que vous prenez je pense par
exemple à la médecine du travail à son
indépendance que vous bafouez dans ce
texte je pens et je pourrais continuer
pendant longtemps à toute une série de
problèmes monsieur le ministre dont la
rédaction même de cet article fait que
nous avons le doute le plus profond sur
la capacité de ce comité à s'en saisir
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le ministre ce comité et probablement
que les partenaires sociaux qui
participeront et notamment les
représentants du monde du travail et des
organisations syndicales s'en
apercevront assez rapidement ce comité
est un jeu de jupe et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous maintenons notre
amendement de
suppression je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
butrell s'il vous plaît vous avez la
parole chers collègues merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre quelques
observations rapide tant de choses ont
été dites partout et et toujours vous
allez nous parlant de simplification et
de
rationalisation à ce sujet vous avez
d'ailleurs travaillé à la promotion d'un
concept celui du
milfeuille dont on constate qu'il est
pour le moins variable puisqu'il
consiste à simplifier en certaines
occasions et dans le cas particulier à
complexifier il est selon moi paradoxal
que vous nous proposiez l'instauration
d'un comité de
pilotage qui ne simplifie pas la lecture
du paysage ni la compréhension des
responsabilités
n'est absolument pas prouvé il vient en
effet se rajouter au corps en matière de
de
prospective ainsi qu'à la commission de
garantie des
retraites mais surtout il vient empiéter
le champ des responsabilités politiques
celle qui incombe au gouvernement que
vous représentez comme celle qui incombe
au au Parlement que que nous
représentons nous faisons un constat par
cet amendement les responsabilités sont
moins identifiées plus diluées sur un
sujet crucial au mieux cet amendement
est
inutile mais il pourrait aussi avoir un
autre objectif celui de vous laisser
davantage les coups des Franches par la
suite vous n'avez pas entendu les
organisations syndicales lorsqu'elles
ont été reçues au
ministère reçu certes mais leur
argumentation ne vous a pas
vous refusez d'entendre aujourd'hui le
mouvement social et vous demandez à
notre assemblée par le biais de cet
amendement et d'autres une sorte de de
chèque en blanc pour ma part avec le
groupe socialiste je défendrai la
responsabilité du Parlement et je ne je
je ne voterai pas l'amendement que vous
proposez je crois que d'ailleurs sur les
band de notre assemblée ce sentiment est
partagé au-delà de la gauche je vous
remercie chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Donis s'il vous
plaît
voilà alors madame Church s'il vous
plaît vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
en
1995 compte tenu de la situation des
comptes sociaux le gouvernement avait
jugé utile de procéder à l'adoption de
la loi organique sur les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale une
telle démarche visée en réalité a
consacrer la fin de la négociation
paritaire pour ce qui concerne les choix
et les orientations en matière de finan
social depuis l'adoption de la loi
organique nous avons eu l'occasion de
discuter de maintes lois de financement
devenu passage obliget de la session
d'automne des lois de financement qui
ont de manière générale consacré la
réduction de la qualité des prestations
sociales
et largement développé la prise en
charge par les assurés eux-mêmes de
leurs dépenses de santé ou encore de la
charge de l'éducation de leurs enfants
nous ne devons que le constater sans
parler du lent mais sû processus qui a
conduit le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
vers une chute régulière et de manière
tout aussi habituel les conseils
d'administration tant de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse que de
la Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
et de la Caisse Nationale d'Assurance
familiale ont très régulièrement
exprimer un avis négatif sur ces lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale
toujours est-il que ces lois ont été
votées les majorités parlementaires
passant outre l'avis des partenaires
sociaux l'équilibre de la réforme Jupé
si l'on peut dire s donc établi sur la
base du cause toujour jour qui fait
qu'en réalité c'est à partir de la
rédaction fixée par le ministère que
s'écrivent les lois de financement ce
rappelle pour vous indiquer que le rejet
que nous avons de ce comité de pilotage
des régimes de retraite se fonde
expressément sur le recul démocratique
que constituerait l'adoption de cet
article prier comment alors même que les
partenaires sociaux ne peuvent se faire
réellement entendre des parlementaire
votant ces lois de financement un comité
de pilotage réuni sous les auspices de
la plus parfaite logique technocratique
et comptable comme le disait ma collègue
Annie
David pourrait-il avoir plus d'écoute de
l'opinion des partenaires sociaux et
comment accepter que ce comité puisse
dicter leur conduite aux représentants
élus de la nation oui monsieur le
ministre le Parlement et bien désaisi
c'est pourtant bel et bien ce schéma qui
est aujourd'hui retenu par votre
gouvernement qu'on ne s'y trompe pas
donner au comité de pilotage le le
pouvoir qu'il est appelé à exercer en
vertu des dispositions de l'article 1er
c'est videré d'une part importante de
leur contenu les lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale et c'est dépéder
plus encore les assurés sociaux
eux-mêmes de leurs droits nous ne
pouvons vous invitez à voter la
suppression de cet article et à marquer
votre choix mes chers collègues face au
3 et demi millions de Français qui se
sont manifestés aujourd'hui par
l'adoption de ces amendements de
suppression par la voix d'un scrutin
public merci je vous remercie madame la
parole est à
Monsieur merci monsieur le
président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
avec cet article se trouve poser à
nouveau la question de l'horison de la
réforme et de son financement il traduit
l'embarras du gouvernement qui se rend
bien compte que sa réforme injuste est
inefficace en tout cas incapable
d'assurer un financement péren des
régimes de retraite en premier lieu vous
proposez de tarir les ressources des
salariés pour financer une crise dont
ils ne sont absolument pas responsables
puisque elle est issue de la spéculation
des banques et des entreprise ensuite
une fois que vous aurez vidé les poches
de toutes ces femmes et ces hommes les
plus modestes subissant les conséquences
de cette crise quelles ressources
allez-vous chercher quel revenus
allez-vous ponctionner certainement pas
ceux des plus riches puisque le
financement de votre réforme à l'image
du bouclier fiscal est financé à hauteur
de 80 % par les salariés et le et les
retraités alors que les plus riches et
les entreprises ne sont mis à
contribution qu'à hauteur de 10 %. votre
réforme
ignorant la dimension humaine du
problème des retraites a pour seul
objectif le retour à l'équilibre pour
plaire aux agences de notation un
équilibre précaire car si nous calculons
le coût pour les finances publiques du
paquet fiscal pour l'été 2007 nous
avoisinons les 34 milliards d'euros un
nouveau passif pour les comptes publics
à combler que vous entendez solder avec
le fond de réserve d'airtite qui s'élève
lui aussi à 34 milliards d'euros voilà
votre sens de l'équilibre basé sur des
principes de trésorerie à court terme
avec ce projet vous ne cherchez qu'à
camoufler au moins jusqu'en 2012 le
gaspillage dont vous êtes responsable
car vous savez bien que dès lors que
vous aurez pillé le fond de réserve des
retraites le problème du financement euh
des retraites sera à nouveau
impitoyablement posé les mesures que
vous aviez engagé en 2003 devaient
pourtant permettre d'assurer l'équilibre
financier des régimes de retraite et ça
n'est effectivement pas le cas voilà
pourquoi les sénateurs du groupe CRG CRC
SPG ont déposé une proposition de loi
garantissant le financement du droit à
la retraite à 60 ans une lecture que je
vous recommande monsieur le ministre car
cette proposition prévoit des mesures de
financement qui ne sont pas basées sur
la fiscalité mais plutôt sur les
contributions sociales dont le
gouvernement ne cesse de proposer des
exonérations et des exemptions je vous
renvoie l'article 2 de cette proposition
qui démontre notre sens de l'équilibre
financier bien différent du votre nous
voulons qu'au sein des entreprises le
partage entre capital et travail soit
rééquilibré en faveur du travail pour
amener les entreprises à transférer le
le bénéfice principalement vers le
financement du travail et les
investissements plutôt que vers les
dividendes à des fins spéculative un
équilibre vous l'avez compris
diamétralement opposé à celui que vous
recherchez c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que je voterai cet amendement et que je
vous invite mes chers collègues à en
faire
autant je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur berb
s'il vous
plaît
oui merci monsieur le Président je
souhaiteraiis donc à mon tour intervenir
sur l'amendement qui a été proposé par
le groupe socialiste et qui souhaite la
suppression de cet article prer tout
simplement parce que le gouvernement et
le Parlement perdrai leurs prérogatives
dans ce projet de loi et je voudrais
également répondre un peu à écho aux
remarques qui ont été faites à la la
fois par Monsieur le Ministre et plus
particulièrement par par monsieur le
rapporteur qui a répondu à l'ensemble
des des orateurs qui ont défendu leur
amendement et de deux phrases m'ont
frappé la première concerne qui concerne
le rapporteur la la première concerne
l'équilibre financier en nous disant il
faut assurer la péritnité Financière
c'est le sens de cet article et
deuxièmement il faut garantir un certain
nombre de un certain niveau de vie des
retraités de deux aveux en quelque sorte
qui montrre que le projet de loi tel
qu'il est proposé est à la fois injuste
et surtout n'est pas pérenne et puis je
voudrais également à l'instar d'un
certain nombre de de mes collègues
m'interroger sur la création de d'un
nouveau comité alors on a appris à
l'instant que ce comité pourrait
s'appeler copie lor je retiens le mot de
copie hein surtout puisque effectivement
on va copier sur un certain nombre de
choses mais on va copier surtout sur les
mauvaises pratiques et en créant ce ce
comité on peut s'interroger je dirais en
contrepartie sur ce que vont devenir les
fonctions des missions respectif des
ministères de la mission d'évaluation et
de contrôle de la sécurité sociale mais
aussi du corps des conseils de
surveillance des caisses de vieillesse
qui d'ailleurs au passage ne se
réunissent pratiquement plus donc on
crée un nouvel organisme et en créant ce
nouvel organisme qui est inutile
puisqu'on l'a vu on par voie de
conséquence on assèche les fonctions de
ceux qui existent déjà deuxième point
sur lequel je voudrais également
intervenir c'est la pérénité financière
de ce ce comité enfit ce comité devrait
assurer une pérénité financière à
travers sa définition et la question que
je me pose est-ce qu'il est je dirais de
de bonnes de bonnes politiques de
confier à une autorité administrative
indépendantes les décisions qui doivent
appartenir au gouvernement et être
contrôlé effectivement par le Parlement
et enfin je voudrais terminer mon
intervention en je dirais m'interrogeant
sur le rôle du du conseil de
surveillance de la de la caisse de la
CNAF euh qui lui ne s'est pas réuni
depuis maintenant 3 ans et surtout sur
les remarques qui ont été faites par par
sa présidente et ça a été rappelé cet
après-midi par notre président du groupe
concernant le financement du projet de
réforme qui nous est présenté cette
dernière a bien dit que le montant n'y
était pas puisque il manquait entre 4 et
5 millions et 400 milliards et
qu'ensuite le la pérennité je dirais de
cette réforme n'était plus assurée à
partir de 2018 donc pour toutes ces
raisons effectivement je soutiens avec
mes collègues socialistes l'amendement
de suppression de cet article 1 et je
vous invite à nous imiter pour
effectivement revenir à des choses plus
sérieuses je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Philip Dominati dernier
orateur monsieur le ministre je vous ai
fait part tout à l'heure des réserves
d'un certain nombre de membres de la
majorité mais après les explications du
rapporteur et vos explications j'ai noté
de deux éléments d'abord le caractère
temporaire je dirais transitoire de la
coexistence peut-être en tout cas c'est
mon interprétation des deux comités
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes dans un
processus évolutif deuxièmement vous
avez réaffirmé que la décision ultime
appartenait au Parlement que dans la
méthodologie vous avez bien phasé les
trois phases concernant les choses
concernant le comité de pilotage et que
la décision ultime reste au Parlement
contrairement à ce que je viens
d'entendre de de la part d'un certain
nombre d'orateurs en conséquence de quoi
nous retirons notre amendement
je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Fortassin qui vient de la
souhaiter monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues ce copilor est un terme
incontestablement tout à fait
séduisant mais ce comité a été
affublé de propos peu flatteur vous
comprendrez que je n'ai pas en rajouté
davantageen simplement ce que je voulais
dire vous essayez monsieur le
ministre de traiter les choses sur un
plan technique alors qu'au fond nous
sommes au cœur d'un débat éminemment
politique le problème majeur quel
est-il c'est que nos concitoyens ils
vous demandent
l'équité or à la limite quand on voit
que les revenus les retraites parce
qu'on peut considérer qu'il s'agit d'une
de de revenus il y a un
écart plus
important que lorsque les gens sont en
activité professionnelle c'est
proprement
scandaleux car on a on arrive pas par ce
biais à reconnaître la dignité de nos
concitoyens or ça c'est un problème
politique ça n'est pas un comité
technique qui va le résoudre et c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec la majorité de
mon groupe nous voterons pour cet
amendement de suppression très
bien monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président je
laap prends très volontiers après
monsieur le sénateur Fortassin et je
voudrais lui dire simplement que bien
entendu je ne crains pas le débat
politique il se trouve simplement que
quand on parle des régime de retraite
malgré tout le le charme et la poésie du
sujet de temps en temps c'est pas
complètement insensé d'ett re quelques
éléments techniques et financiers et je
vous prie de m'en excuser mais on a vu
sur l'article 5 et sur l'article 6 que
nous avions quand même eu je crois un
débat qui était un débat bien alimenté
d'ailleurs notamment par les remarques
de l'opposition qui était également un
débat politique et monsieur le sénateur
je vous assure que je ne fuis pas le
débat politique je voudrais dire
d'ailleurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de l'opposition que je ne fie
pas non plus la notion d'équilibre
financier la seule chose que j'ai noté à
la suite de plusieurs de vos
intervention c'est qu'il faudrait
quasiment que nous soyons en position de
nous excuser parce que nous avons comme
objectif d'avoir des régimes qui soient
des régimes de retraite équilibrée ça me
paraît pas complètement insensé que de
penser que dans une réforme des
retraites on puisse effectivement
aspirer avoir des régimes qui soient des
régimes équilibrés et je ne rentre pas
dans un jeu qui est un jeu de sémantique
pour savoir si c'est trop pas assez la
vérité c'est que l'équilibre des
retraites c'est quelque chose auquel
nous sommes attachés parce que nos
concitoyens sont attachés à ce que leur
retraite puissent être puissent être
versé une fois que j'ai dit ça deux ou
trois éléments d'information et de
réponse un peu plus pardonnez-moi un peu
plus précis encore par rapport au
différentes interventions la première
pour dire à Madame David je crois
également que Madame chersch l'a évoqué
que je ne crois pas mais franchement pas
que nous puissions dire que le Parlement
dans ce texte ou par ce texte se
retrouve désaisi en quoi que ce soit y
compris par le copyor je voudrais
simplement rappeler à nouveau parce que
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure que c'est
bien par ce texte de loi que nous
réintroduisons le vote par le Parlement
des mesures d'âge concernant les régimes
de retraite c'est en 1985 mesdames et
messieurs en en 1985 que c'est passé du
régime législatif au régime
réglementaire et c'est en 2010 que ça va
passer du régime réglementaire au régime
législatif c'est-à-dire que le pouvoir
que vous avez pris du pouvoir législatif
pour le donner au pouvoir réglementaire
nous le rendons au Parlement donc tout
naturellement je le dis sur ce point-là
mais si si si non non je le rends pas à
l'UMP je le rends au Parlement et
Monsieur carer vous êtes pessimiste sur
votre capacité demain à pouvoir exercer
les responsabilité je vous comprends
mais cela dit c'est au Parlement que
nous rendons et en l'occurrence
actuellement la majorité est une
majorité qui n'est pas une majorité
socialiste mais ça change rien au fond
du sujet c'est bien le Parlement qui
part ce texte est ressaisi d'un pouvoir
qui était passé au pouvoir règlementaire
en 1985 et je le redis parce que c'est
la stricte vérité en second lieu je
voulais répondre à Monsieur Cardon comme
à monsieur vaotrel qui ont fait une
remarque que je trouve assez sensé au
demeurant sur la simplification du
paysage administratif mais tout à fait
c'est pas parce que vous dites quelque
moi je rentre pas dans la logique est un
peu la votre parfois quand ils disent
blanc dit noir quand vous dites quelque
chose de sensé je vous donne tout à fait
raison et vous avez dit quelque chose de
sensé et donc vous avez dit il ne faut
pas qu'il y ait création d'un organisme
il ne faut pas qu' création d'un
organisme qui soit comme ça une création
qui vient compliquer les choses c'est la
raison pour laquelle monsieur le
sénateur je vous précise
qu'effectivement il y a le copyor qui
est mis en place mais que simultanément
il y a la conférence de revalorisation
la commission de garantie et le comité
de pilotage pour l'emploi des seniors
qui sont supprimés comme vous le
constatez il y a donc un organisme
nouveau mais trois organismes qui sont
supprimés votre remarque était pleine de
bon sens et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous l'avions devancé en ce qui
concerne monsieur telade la remarque que
vous avez faites vous-même sur la
légitimité par rapport aux organismes
élus je voudrais me permettre de vous
faire remarquer que le corps a une
légitimité que personne ne conteste je
me suis permis tout à l'heure de
rappeler d'ailleurs qu'il fallait pas
avoir une vision trop trop trop critique
ni trop simplifiée de des des du
diagnostic qu'il a émis je voudrais vous
dire que nous sommes exactement dans la
même logique il y a effectivement le
copilor donc vous avez dit qu'il n'avait
pas la légitimité démocratique je vous
ai montré je crois pourquoi est-ce que
nous rendions au Parlement des pouvoirs
qu'il n'avait plus je dis très
clairement les choses que ce soit le
corps ou que ce soit le copyor il a une
capacité d'expertise pour le premier et
j'allais presque dire de suggestion ou
d'inflexion pour le second cela ne remet
en rien en cause bien entendu la qualité
des avis qu'il rend et en dernier lieu
je voudrais dire à Madame Church que
souvent le le le enfin le la référence
qui était faite au aux années 95- 96
laisse à penser que il y avait justement
d saaisissement du Parlement mais je
voudrais bien rappeler à ce sujet que
c'est bien en 1996 qu'ont été instaurés
les PLFSS qui donne au Parlement la
possibilité d'avoir un vrai débat sur
une partie importante des finances
publiques qui lui échappaent de telle
sorte qu'aujourd'hui nous ayons vous
ayez en tant que parlementaire la
capacité de vous exprimer sur ces
sujets-l ce n'était pas le cas
auparavant c'est le cas aujourd'hui ça
me paraît tout à fait important je
voudrais en dernier lieu madame me
permettre de vous faire remarquer
puisque vous avez dit que l'ensemble des
organismes qui avent été consultés
avaient émis un avis négatif sur sur le
texte je voudrais simplement vous dire
que le conseil d'administration de
laacnav a rendu un avis positif et c'est
pas rien c'est la raison pour laquelle
je crois que là encore il fallait
nuancer le propos qui donnait à penser
que tout était critique non c'est pas
critique je termine simplement en vous
disant puisque c'est le fond du sujet
que c'est évidemment plus facile de ne
rien faire je dis pas que c'est ce que
vous préconisez mais il serait plus
facile de ne rien faire vu la situation
des finances des régimes de retraite je
vous dis très clairement les choses nous
prenons les responsabilité et nous les
assumons
totalement
je vous remercie monsieur le minist j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par Madame la président du groupe
crcspg je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable sur ces
quatre amendements nous procéderons par
un un vote unique et que l'avis du
Gouvernement également est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du rgl ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront au secrétaire un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettront un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettront un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
minutes
le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos j'invite madame et
monsieurs le les secrétaires à procéder
au dépouillement du
scrutin
scutin numéro
17 sur les amendements numéro 1 64 251
et 319
rectifié amendement de suppression de
l'article 1er du projet de loit portant
réforme des retraites nombre de votants
341 nombre de suffrages exprimés
339 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
170 pour l'adoption
154 contre
185 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté nous passons maintenant à trois
amendements sur ce même article faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 860 qui le
présente le groupe CRC qui présente le
groupe l'amendement 860 monsieur ficher
vous le
présentez
non c'est qui c'est moi Madame mat merci
monsieurésant c'est vous qui le
présentez vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président nous avons déjà
exprimé notre opposition quant à la
création de ce Comité de
pilotage et et nous réaffirmons notre
désaveux tant sur le fond d'ailleurs que
sur la forme puisqu'il traduit quand
même la volonté du gouvernement de
n'envisager la réforme des retraites que
d'un point de vue exclusivement
comptable que vous le niez ou non
monsieur le ministre et vous ne prenez
en compte ni les attentes ni les besoins
légitimes de la
population de plus une partie des
missions confiées à ce comité recoupe
celle déjà exercé par le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui a lui
l'intérêt d'être réellement pluraliste
dans sa composition et d'avoir acquis
depuis sa création en 2000 une
légitimité
certaine en effet nous estimons que la
composition de ce comité telle qu'elle
est présentée et prévue dans ce texte
n'est en rien
satisfaisante pas satisfaisante d'abord
parce qu'elle ne garantit pas une
véritable représentation des partenaires
sociaux pas satisfissante encore car
c'est un décret de l'exécutif qui
décidera au final de la composition et
des modalités d'organisation de ce
comité ce qui va à l'encontre de la
transparence démocratique que nos
concitoyens premiers concernés
d'ailleurs par le sujet sont en droit
d'attendre
sur le fond maintenant nous pensons que
la question du pilotage de nos régimes
de retraite est un sujet non pas
technique mais absolument politique il
s'agit de veiller au maintien et à la
défense des droits des assurés et de la
solidarité poumon de notre système de
retraite par
répartition sinon cela équivaudrait à ce
que nous législateurs acceptions d'être
déposséder de cette question au profit
d'un comité ad hoc la question si
stratégique du pilote des régimes de
retraite doit être assuré par l'exécutif
et par le législatif et chacun est dans
son rôle la réécriture qui a subi cet
article lors de son examen par la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat qui a considérablement réduit les
mission et la portée de ce comité montre
qu'ilinpire guerre
d'enthousiasme aussi c'est pourquoi nous
vous proposons avec cette amendement qui
est un amendement de repli cependant la
de suppression de limiter l'émission de
ce comité a un strict rôle de
proposition je vous remercie ma cher
collègue l'amendement 65 qui le présente
au groupe
socialiste le
65 Monsieur telade Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
s'il vous plaît
oui je monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je me suis déjà exprimé tout à
l'heure sur le la teneur de cet
amendement et en vous disant que il y
avait une solution qui était
l'amendement de repli que nous
proposions pour faire en sorte que ce
comité de pilotage reste dans son rôle
et en particulier son rôle de de conseil
mais que la décision devait rester aux
organismes élus nous avons donc fait la
proposition de remplacer le mot et je le
répète le comité de pilotage à
promission de veiller par fait des le
comité de pilotage fait des propositions
au gouvernement et au Parlement afin que
ceci veille à cet amendement a pour but
de ramener le comité de pilotage à son
véritable rôle et c'est dans ce sens-là
que cet amendement de repli nous
permettrait en quelque sorte de
continuer à maintenir l'existance de ce
comité sans développer de polémiques
inutiles je vous remercie chers
collègues qui présente le
861 c'est
qui madame Church madame Church vous
avez la parole
ou monsieur hatin je sais pas merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues donc le comité de pilotage des
régimes de retraite le copilor doit
veiller au respect des missions du
régime de retraite à la pérenité
financière l'équité du système de
retraite l'amélioration du niveau de vie
des retraités du niveau des pensions et
le rapprochement des règles et des
paramètres entre les différents régimes
entre autres outre le fait que certaines
de ces affirmations sont contradictoires
avec les dispositions détaillées dans le
texte notamment comme nous l'avons
évoqué précédemment en terme
d'amélioration du niveau de vie des
retraités nous regrettons la
prédominance accord aux objectifs
budgétaires et comp monsieur le ministre
nous le redisons la moitié des objectifs
assignés à ce comité révèle la véritable
obception de votre gvernement
l'équilibre comptable je voudrais à ce
titre citer Paul Krugman prix Nobel
d'économie 2008 il écrit et il dit
l'élite des responsables politiques les
banquiers centraux les ministres des
Finances les élus qui se dressent en
défenseur de la vertu budgétaire
agissent comme les prêtres d'un culte
antique exigeant que nous nous livrions
à des sacrifices humains pour apaiser la
colère des dieux invisible fin de
citation les dieux en question ici les
dieux en question ici ne sont finalement
pas invisibles ils se nomme agence de
notation et marchés financiers il s'agit
finalement de sacrifier le travail au
nom du
capital nous nous opposons à cette
logique qui semble aujourd'hui être le
maître mot de vos politiques nous ne
pouvons cautionner une action politique
qui traite les travailleurs comme une
entrée d'argent et le et les retraités
comme une dépense coûteuse la quantité
ne peut être un objectif en soi et c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de remplacer un
des critères quantitatif de la loi par
l'affirmation d'un objectif
qualitatif le comité de pilotage des
retraite des régimes de retraite doit
assurer l'existence d'un système de
retraite
fondé sur l'épanouissement en dehors des
activités professionnelles c'est ce que
disent les 3 millions et demi entre
autres de personnes qui manifestent
aujourd'hui et ils y sont attachés les
hommes et les femmes ayant étudié puis
travaillé tout au long de leur existence
qui ont consacré l'essentiel de leur vie
à devenir et être des forces de
production doivent pouvoir être délivré
de cette contrainte en accédant à une
retraite
satisfaisante cela implique de
considérer la retraite comme un
véritable temps de vie et non un résidu
accordé gracieusement en fin de vie cela
nécessite d'accorder une pension au
montant suffisant et non de la tronquer
au maximum nous plaidons pour un temps
Dee de vie libéré et délier des
contraintes du travail nous défendons le
seul droit à la retraite qui mérite ce n
celui qui ne se définit pas simplement
en opposition au travail soit un temps
qui rejette ceux qui ne sont plus utile
qui n'ont plus assez de valeur
productive mais un moment de vie en
bonne santé véritable période
d'épanouissement et c'est pourquoi nous
vous demandons d'adopter cet amendement
je vous remercie tant mieux ça fait
gagner du
temps ah non 66 ah oui non avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président oui chers
collègues vous nous proposez donc euh
quelques nouvelles réécriture par
rapport à la à l'alinéa pardon 4 hein de
l'article 1er qui euh parle donc du
fameux comité de pilotage or à la
commission nous avons essayé justement
euh ce euh euh cet article premer d'en
réécrire comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure euh un petit peu euh le sens
afin d'insister sur deux choses la
première et c'est vraiment l'objet de
cet alinéa bien sûr c'est de
reprendre ce qui
est ce que nous avons discuté en début
de propos c'est-à-dire les objectifs de
l'assurance vieillesse on les a codifié
dans le cadre de la sécurité sociale et
le
deuxème but de cette réécriture c'était
bien de dire et de rendre opérationnel
et stratégique
la finalité donc du comité de pilotage
estimant que le travail fait donnait un
meilleur
équilibre au texte du qui concerne le
comité de pilotage pour bien dire aussi
que ce comité
veillera au bon équilibre financier du
système puisque je le répète il sera
chargé donc d'une procédure
d'alerte identique au comité de pilotage
de longam et je tiens à réaffirmer une
FO is de plus mais on l'a déjà dit qu'il
ne substitue pardon en rien au pouvoir
exécutif et bien évidemment législatif
qui gardent toutes leurs prérogatives
donc pour toutes ces raisons monsieur le
Président c'est un avis défavorable de
la
commission je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre avis de
la commission sur ces amendements oui
monsieur monsieur président merci on un
mot j'ai déjà répondu je crois aux
orateurs pour dire donc que l'avis est
défavorable sur les trois amendements
pour les deux premers parce que comme je
l'ai expliqué il n'y a pas
d'essaisissement bien au contraire du
rôle du Parlement et puis sur le dernier
amendement c'est simplement parce que
même si les objectifs qui sont
poursuivis sont tout à fait nobles mais
ils nous paraissent difficilement
quantifiables et de ce fait je crois que
plus prosaïquement plus modestement si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi nous en restons
aux objectifs qui sont dans le texte
donc c'est
défavorable je vous remercie infiniment
alors nous allons nous exprimer sur le
860 y a-t-il des explications de vote
il n'y en a
pas je pardon monsur F monsieur ficher
ah oui
mais vous êtes moins moins agile
aujourd'hui non mais ça fait très
longtemps que je nai pas parlé allez
vous avez la
parole alors c'est un cet amendement
860 est un amendement de repli à autre
amendement de suppression du comité de
pilotage des régimes de retraite créé
par l'article 1 du projet de loi alors
nous l'avons dit ce comité de pilotage
de suscite guerre d'enthousiasme et pour
cause comment nous parlementaires
pourrions-nous accepter d'être
dépossédés et au travers de nous les
citoyens du pouvoir de décision portant
sur des questions aussi fondamentales
que le respect des objectifs du système
de retraite par répartition et la
garantie de sa pérennité financière
alors nous défendons au contraire le
maintien du contrôle législatif des
mesures correctrices concernant les
régimes de retraite c'est au
gouvernement et non et au Parlement et
non à ce comité de pilotage qu'il
revient de prendre des décision en la
matière parce qu'on fait prendre des
décisions par les comités de pilotage et
puis après on s'aperçoit que ça revient
c'est un peu comme les recommandations
de la Cour des comptes si vous voulez et
bien souvent on retrouve ces
recommandations et bien dans des textes
législatives qui ont été réécrites d'une
autre façon aucun contournement du rôle
du Parlement ne serurait être toléré sur
cette question alors en ce sens on ne
peut que s'étonner et s'inquiéter de
voir que la présidence de ce comité de
pilotage est confié au ministre en
charge de la sécurité sociale d'autant
que c cette indication étonnamment ne
figure pas dans le projet de loi déposé
par le gouvern mais dans l'étude
d'impact qui précise aussi que les
ministres de tutelle en feront également
partie double incongruité quand on sait
que c'est ce même comité de pilotage
présidé par le ministre en charge et
composé des ministres de tutelle qui
sera consulté en 2018 par le
gouvernement sur un projet de réforme
destiné à maintenir l'équilibre du
système de retraite au-delà de 2020 et
nos concitoyens ont bien raison de faire
du souci en somme c'est un peu le
gouvernement qui conseillera le
gouvernement c'est ça monsieur le
ministre de plus c'est toujours à la
faveur d'un décret et non selon un mode
de désignation démocratique que seront
fixé la composition exacte et les
modalités d'organisation de ce comité
alors le passage par le décret donc par
la seule décision de l'exécutif est en
contradiction avec les règles minimales
donc de transparence aussi si comité il
doit y avoir bien qu'on regarde une
partie de ses missions et de sa
composition même sa coexistence au côté
du corps paraît superflu il ne saurait
avoir un rôle décisionnaire et doit être
contené à un simple rôle de
proposition mon cher collègue il n'y a
pas d'autre explication de vote je
consulte ceux qui sont favorables à cet
amendement numéro 860 veille bien lever
la main
avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté
oui oui voulez qu'on fasse à Paris
président ficher ah
bon bien merci sur le
65 y y a-t-il des explications de vote
il n'y en a pas qui est pour
l'amendement
65 qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté sur le
861 y y a-t-il madame David vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le
Président je voulais juste vous rappeler
en fait ce qui était cet amendement je
suis pas bien sûr que dans les
explications du ministre et du
rapporteur on est bien compris en fait
nous vous proposions d'inscrire dans la
dans l' mission de ce com la p qu'il
vise aussi la pérenité d'un système de
retraite fondé sur l'épanouissement des
hommes et des femmes voilà vous venez de
suivre en direct dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat la séance consacrée à l'examen de
l'article 1 le premier article du projet
de loi sur les retraites les articles
décisifs ayant déjà été discutés
consacré vous l'avez entendu à des
questions assez techniques sur le
pilotage de la des régimes de retraite
mais le véritable enjeu ici et on le
sent bien c'est le calendrier maintenant
du débat une chose est sûre contenu des
800 amendements qui restent en
discussion ce débat ne se terminera pas
avant la fin de la semaine avant le
weekend les sénateurs de l'opposition
sont notamment mobilisés pour défendre
pied à pied point par point l'ensemble
de leurs amendements pour maintenir ce
débat au moins jusqu'à la manifestation
qui va avoir lieu samedi pour ne pas
démobiliser pour ne pas donner
l'impression que tout est joué alors à
la différence de ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale où vous vous en
souvenez le président de l'Assemblée
avait coupé cours aux discussions et
bien ils ne veulent pas imaginer les
sénateurs de l'opposition que le
président du Sénat Gérard Larché puisse
lui aussi utiliser des techniques
parlementaires pour essayer d'accélérer
les choses avant le weekend et donc on
en sera plus demain puisque il y a ce
qu'on appelle la Conférence des
présidents qui va décider de l'ordre du
jour mais a priori c'est donc un long
débat que peuvent s'attendre les
sénateurs et ce soir même à une très
longue soirée pour examiner la suite de
ces articles je vous le disais assez
technique qui sont assez loin des des
même des préoccupations des manifestants
mais à travers des discussions serrées
l'opposition veut bien se faire l'écho
des attentes de la rue ici et montrer
qu'il y a encore des points à gagner des
éléments à gagner et montrer que le
débat n'est pas terminé on va vous
retrouver tout de suite Michel grossior
pour faire le point sur cette journée de
mobilisation à la fois ici au Sénat et
bien sûr dans la réu bonsoir Michel
bonsoir Emmanuel effectivement il est
19h passé de quelques secondes c'est
l'heure du journal sur Public
Sénat